hey
[Music]
hello and welcome everybody to romania
to the sixth stop of the grand chess
tour here in bucharest we start day one
in front of the triumph arch one of the
most iconic places here in bucharest
every single 1st of december the
romanian army parades underneath the
arch we have a chess parade of our own
let's go to the studio and start this
exciting day with jen maurice and
alejandro
[Music]
thank you christian i am jennifer
shahadian we welcome back to our grand
chess tour coverage we are in romania
for the super bet rapid and blitz chess
and i'm here with grandmaster alejandra
ramirez well what a pleasure to be here
jen an amazing series of tournaments
we've had in the last couple of months
but it's good to be back on the
granchester we have some amazing games
coming up for you and i'm excited to
cast here at the super bet rapid and
blitz
yes it's going to be a great event let's
take a look at the cast of characters we
have as some of your favorites including
a very confident wesley so who just
dispatched the world chess champion in
norway fisher random but still that is
one heck of a confidence builder i think
a lot of people don't see it as proper
chess in my opinion that still demands
the calculation the positional strength
those things the confidence that makes a
great chess player and i think wesley
still coming out of a huge demolition of
the world champion is going to feel very
confident as a top seed here in
bucharest and then we also have some of
our favorites fabiano caruana lavonna
as well as some colorful wild cards to
round out the field
but let's take a look at the format
before we go deeper into that ten player
round robin rapid chess
nine games and the time controls game 25
with a 10 second delay
there are two points at stake at each
rapid game and that means that there
will be one point at stake for each
blitz game the schedule is familiar to
those of you who are grand chess tour
fans as we will have five days of
non-stop action three days of rapid
followed by two days of blitz and
potential playoffs live coverage
beginning at 2 50 local time in romania
and meanwhile in the studio here in st
louis it'll start at 7 50 each day
and with us we have grandmaster maurice
ashley to go over
some of the possibilities as we eye
towards london
well thank you jen and indeed we had so
many events before this one it was
abhijan there was zagreb there was paris
there was the st louis rapid and blitz
and the sink field cup but it's come
down to these last couple of events and
for some players time is simply running
out they've got to perform as you see
here the cast of characters that make up
the grand chess tour 2019 but several of
them have already played four events and
that is crucial for the possibilities
for london well atop the list we see
magnus carlsen and ding loren they are
virtually guaranteed the top two spots
not even disasters could keep them out
of making it to london but other players
they are hanging on by their fingernails
fabiano caruana and sergey kayakin are
the best of the lot
they have to win here no question about
it if they want to have any chance of
qualifying jana pavianchi of course will
play in india and he will have to win
that event as well good luck with that
he'll have magnus and ding and ikaru
nakamura to face and we see there hikaru
nakamura he's simply knocked out no
chance to win at all and
remember giroff who's playing here but
they could play spoiler who could they
be spoiling well we're gonna find out
some more as we jump to grand master
christian carrillo in bucharest
thank you maurice and welcome everybody
to bucharest it's a beautiful setting
here at the stagiary country club
yesterday we had an amazing reception
boris becker the famous tennis player
was in the house he played the game
against fabiano caruana maybe he tired
the challenger a little bit but of
course maurice you mentioned fabiano and
sergey who are in a position in a
must-win position they have to score big
in this event to even have a chance to
qualify to london
three other players that are sitting
quite comfortably right now of course
i'm talking about lev neronia who is
sitting in the fourth position right now
with 25 and a half points of course he's
coming
from batumi georgia where the european
team championship was going on and he
only led his team to a fourth place
position surely a disappointing result
for him he likes that gold medal but uh
of course it has a lot of energy he's uh
he's in pole position to qualify to
london 25 points and a half he needs six
and a half points average from the past
from the next two events he's going to
play here he's going to play also in
india so he's in a great position right
now the second player that i want to
focus on is of course vishwanathan anand
who is only one point and a half uh
behind leveronian and he still has two
events left this one in uh in bucharest
and of course he's going to go back to
his home country where he's simply a god
he's going to gather the strength and
energy of his people and he's going to
try to deliver a message in india and
qualify for the final four in london and
of course the last but not least the new
world champion of course fisher random
world champion not regular chess wesley
so the energy is high for that one the
confidence is high with this one so
definitely we're going to have some fire
on the on the board i'm looking forward
to some exciting games
and let's take a look at what we have
for our first course as the round one
pairings are of course set and we've got
some really good matchups alejandro as i
i love this fabiano lavon battle because
it's going to give us a lot of insight
into whether or not bobby can do it and
win this event and give himself a chance
for a ticket to london i think maurice
mentioned it fabiano needs to win the
event he actually needs to win clear
first to really secure that spot in
london and he will not do it if he
doesn't start with a victory against
lebanon he needs to start strong he has
the white pieces he traditionally does
well against levon remember that he won
against him in the london chess classic
last year in the top four so i think
this is a game that's very important for
fabiano but i also like this matchup of
the wild card vladislav artemyev playing
against vishyanan vishi who has really
good chances in my opinion still to make
it to london he needs a couple of good
results he had a really great
performance here in st louis and i want
to see him he's traditionally been a
very strong rapid player he even won the
rapid world championship just a couple
of years ago and i want to see him in
london in that top four so i will be
rooting for him on the other hand
vladimir tell me if he's been the talk
of the town this year he won gibraltar
he had an amazing performance in the
world team championship in kazakhstan
and i know he's trying to make a name
for himself against the very top players
in the world and that will be the the
youngest verse the most experienced
pairing that's a good way to get it
started i think artemia is going to have
a great event and i want to see if he's
going to actually fight for the first
few places that's a good question as a
matter of fact i think you got to wonder
will a wild card win we've seen wild
cards get destroyed i mean just
absolutely well not magnus carlsen but
he's nobody's wildcard
when he didn't play because of the world
championship beard
nobody wants to see magnets across the
board but here's one wild card of course
lee kuan yew who's won a world blitz
title wanted back in 2013 so he knows
that he can play some quick chess and
he's going to be upsetting quite a few
players will he be the one will it be
anton korobov of the ukraine or as you
mentioned
atemive they really have some decent
chances they could make a run we did see
you young yi put it together when he
showed up so
will this be the one no magnus no naka
no nippo and no dingler in all the big
time favorites are playing in india so
this one is certainly one they might be
able to steal yeah and speaking of the
wild cards let's talk about anton
korobov he's not a name a household name
at the top level of chess he's not a
2700 player but his rapid skills are
just impressive you saw the list that we
had at the beginning he's actually the
number two seed of the tournament
despite his standard rating or his
classical rating being almost 100 points
lower than the average of the field
number six in the world in rapid as a
matter of fact he's an amazing rapid
player i've seen him play blitz i've
seen him play rapid he's just a beast i
remember that i was pretty happy with my
fourth place in the aeroflot open i was
just trailing that guy
by miles he won the aeroflot blitz open
easily with sergey karyakin with la
quang liam with some of the big stars of
the blitz chess world and he wanted no
problem and here he is here he is he's
ready to play let's see if christian has
other thoughts from bucharest
well of course one of the big matchups
also i think is the one between uh anish
giri and wesley so wesley of course as
we were mentioning he's coming back from
that huge victory uh at the world
championship uh official official random
world championship in norway but giri
has more or less qualified the
candidates that was a huge boost in
energy for him surely and uh in this one
his only role is to play the spoilers
role so he's definitely going to try to
uh to kick in first gear in in the first
game against wesley so well i think that
and there we go the wild cards and the
players who no longer have a chance to
qualify for london um on a positive note
they can just focus on trying to win
this event and that is a great thing
about the grand chest store to me it is
really prestigious to become the friend
just to tour champion i mean that
is an incredible title you have for life
but winning any event is also a title in
its own right
actually just a small correction geary
does have right a maybe one percent
chance if he wins this event and he gets
at least second place in the next event
good luck with that but if he does that
he will overtake maxine vashila grav and
have a real chance of qualifying that
actually that would virtually qualify
him unless the other players ahead of
him like uh wesley or or anan or lavon
they would actually both have to
all have to do badly but still there is
a chance for him to qualify if he
manages to win both of them i think you
got it about right maurice probably
about one percent and the thing about
this one percent is more of a
psychological uh effect on the players
that as long as there is this one
percent they cling on to this hope and
they play different and you'll see it a
lot of times as soon as the hope is gone
mathematically their play changes it can
be looser maybe the pressure is soft
there's a lot of different things but it
is different
opening move being made there
as they start
and it looks like somebody played c4 for
bobby c4 for five let's see if it stays
he has been playing he's had a lot of
four games lately in the grand swiss he
did employ c4 quite often so it wouldn't
shock me if he stays it looks like he's
not instinctively bringing it back
there it is there you go just watch just
the top yeah
are you because you know like when
somebody makes a bat a move that
somebody doesn't want to play they
usually instinctively pull it right back
right yeah
but we're off and this is a topical
variation already i guess we're starting
with the game between fabiano caruana
and levon aronian but this english
opening has been
thematic for the past three or four
months it just seems that you see it in
every tournament at every level
and especially in the world cup i saw a
lot of scintillating games with this
specific variation by the way we should
point out it is extraordinarily
important to do well in rapid rapid has
double the points of blitz and you find
almost always the majority of times the
player who wins the rapid wins the
entire event so don't think because
they're 18 blitz games there's a lot of
room to catch up good luck with that
usually it's the player who wins rapid
and so these players have to get off to
a great start and will be trailing
otherwise they'll be trailing a leader
that'll be very difficult to catch
and we already have an amazing position
for us guys this is
starting off the tournament in the
correct note as you can see levon
aronian has played the move g5 trapping
this knight on h4 this is all theory but
it's very very strange theory you can
see already
fabiano playing the move d4
this goes into incredibly weird channels
if black takes on h4 the problem is that
after bishop g5 your position more or
less collapses you don't have a good way
of defending the knight on f6 and you
lose a ton of material for this reason
levon very quickly played the move h6
not only defending the pawn but also the
square on g5 that allows you to take the
knight on h4 on the next move it is
still trapped on h4 but this is
obviously not the end of theory let's
see what fabi has prepared he has played
the move bishop e3 pretty quickly and
this is already a mess i don't remember
the move bishop b3 then again i'm not
very familiar with the movie so now is
so now if g takes h4 um already on the
board g takes h4 and immediately bishop
takes h6 renewing the threat of bishop
g5 yes you don't really want to take
this rook it's not a very
worthy rook it doesn't do anything for
the moment and that would pull you
behind the material two pieces for a
rook and a pawn you actually want to
keep the bishop threatening the king on
g8 and especially this bishop g5 move at
the moment is a big difficulty for black
this bishop on b4 is also tactically
trapped so take so get rid of that beast
said lavon oronion
takes d5 both on the board in an
immediate 97. and now we see how fabi
can continue there's a couple of ways to
try to regain material of course you can
always take on our fate but as we said
that relinquishes the initiative there
is an idea usually to play them with
queen a4 that tends to trap the bishop
on b4 but i'm not really sure if it
works and this moment so the engine
gives it as the number one move right
now best move is queen a4 and that
bishop will be trapped with the a3 idea
as you mentioned what about c what what
about c5 um yeah the problem with the
move
c5 i'm looking at the a5 square trying
to untrap my bishop as you guys are
trying to play a3 is that usually i can
take on c6
and if you take back with the knight d5
will hit the knight and you don't have a
good way of defending this bishop on b4
if i were to play queen a5 there then
well
after 1965. then that's it's okay for um
for white supposedly because here i can
still regain my peace i have a three at
the end but i can also throw in bishop
takes that fate before i go and try to
regain my material on the queen side
anyway it's really murky no matter
really what happens and it seems like
favi is either remembering his theory
he's a little bit out of theory
it feels like white should be better in
this particular position because after
queen a4 i'm having difficulties giving
back the piece for black but achieving
equality why queen a4 instead of queen
um well i guess we have to play queen a4
yeah they're the reason the a5 square
queen either would be just bishop a5 and
that's a little bit of a detail if you
play the move queen b3 then the bishop
will be happily posted on b6 pretty safe
out of harm's way you need to make sure
that the a5 square is unavailable for
this bishop on before that's why queen
a4 is the most natural move to me
in this position yeah queen a4
um fabiano still thinking in this
position but likely he's seen this and
kind of trying to remember his theory
right he definitely knows the idea
because it's a very common motif of the
position that the whole variation hinges
upon the fact that after queen a4 the
bishop doesn't have a retreat he might
be thinking whether he wants to throw in
bishop takes that fate first or not and
i'm kind of curious on how it changes
the evaluation of the position because
if cuneifor is going to trap your bishop
you might think why don't i just capture
the rook first and then
uh try to capture this bishop on before
i'm assuming there's kind of some
tactical trick
if i take back on f8 but i'm not really
finding it uh
bishop yeah it relinquishes right it
really pushes the d2 square just an
extra but important tempo that black has
and that would force me to play e3
otherwise black plays e3 himself and
that should be good enough to escape
with the bishop we've seen lavon get up
from the board looking very relaxed like
he knows he's okay that's a bit
surprising in this short position you
can imagine the players of the past
looking at this position and saying this
is how the english transpire is in the
modern era like it's supposed to be a
solid quiet opening i remember when i
used to play it i remember people saying
to me man you like to play that slow
boring positional stuff take a look at
this kind of position there's nothing
like that here and i don't know who
decided to pick this game because it
wasn't us
but somehow it's turned out to be the
wildest game of the round all the other
games are pretty much going along solid
lines the games will proceed to pace so
some end games even end games are
appearing already this one though this
is no end game this one is wild i have a
variation here on the board that could
have happened but i'm going to show you
what has transpired he did not take
he did not play queen a4 he actually
immediately played bishop takes only for
now down material but collecting pawns
he hopes will be enough as the king side
is fractured we'll see if this works out
for him yeah i mean e3 queen h5
there's some really dangerous ideas here
that don't involve uh trapping the
bishop on before but involved trapping
the king on g8 i think it's one of the
difficulties for white when you have
this choices over the board do you
capture the material with queen a4 or do
you believe in your initiative and it's
not an easy call especially in a rapid
game you see these bishops on h6 and e4
you can see as you mentioned this e3 and
the queen swinging to the king side it
is all very tempting
but black is up a piece this will this
be enough we'll find out very soon let's
see if christian carrillo has some
insights for us
talking about sergey karjaking needing
to win this tournament and he's playing
a scintillating game against korobov
of course we have the typical nidorf
after a6 and here you can play bishop e3
you can play bishop g5 you can do
anything but bishop d3 is a very strange
approach you usually don't put the
bishop there maybe you can put it on e2
and then on f3 but on d3 not so much and
in this position corabov chooses to go
g6 he's taking the dragon approach and
now okay you want to play the dragon of
course the bishop on d3 is not ideally
placed in the dragon but still is a
dragon it's considered to be a
suspicious opening bishop e3 bishop g7
we're shifting gears f3 b5
queen d2 bishop b7 and i think we have
some more moves this is the position we
currently have on the board of course
most likely white is not going to castle
alongside anymore he's going to go short
castle but the structure uh for black
looks terrible
it looks like white is just having an
incredible advantage already this uh
square on b5 is going to be a weakness
forever and i don't see the counter
chances for black of course if you go
short castle as black at some point i'm
always going to have the option of
launching an attack on the kingside even
if i castle kingside so i'm seeing uh
sergey as the definite favor in this one
i mean
you're dissing the dragon and i'm i'm
reading on wikipedia that dracula is
actually derived from
the dragon so i i don't know i i'm not
so sure the story checks out yeah i
don't know dragon is playable the dragon
is a trash opening but what it's
complete garbage but moving moving on
we do have a couple of games we should
update this one particularly between
anish giri and wesley so definitely not
the most exciting one of the round let's
just take a look at the kind of end game
that they've gotten themselves into you
could claim that white is minimally
better because he does have a bishop
against the night the king is a little
bit more active you can see it in the
center of the board as maybe we can pull
up the sure
if we could get our king to the d5
square that would be amazing right that
pawn we're in e5 if the king could jump
to b5 then of course white has some
chances but it's very far from doing so
as soon as it lands on d3 i'm gonna have
this knight jumping to e5 with check
preventing you from moving the king
further up the board this should end in
a draw with good play but of course if
anybody has some chances it's a niche
theory in my opinion we have so much
action everywhere else to be spending
too much time on this game
yeah we don't wake up for 4 a.m for this
game no definitely not but bobby's game
on the other hand yes bobby's game is
definitely the one that we have to keep
our eyes on levon is now taking his
sweet time on how to respond to bishop
takes e4 of course in preparation queen
a4 is what the engine was throwing out
it is the natural way of recapturing the
material but i like that fabi is adding
a little bit of fire here to the game
seeing how he's going to continue bishop
take c4 doesn't have a real threat
because e3 queen h5 still takes some
time and even when you do that
f5 needs to be considered from the black
side so i could be threatening just to
renew the idea of queen i4 with an extra
pawn um as black here how do you feel
about sticking something on f5 like a
bishop f5 a knight f5
i think the most natural thing for me to
at least from a human perspective is to
put the pawn on f5 and the reason i want
to do that is that it creates space
around the king and it's one of the
typical ways of defending a king to give
it some space and to remove space from
your opponent on the other hand it does
kind of strategically weaken all of my
squares and this bishop on ca just feels
like it's really really awkward once
that i put my pawn there so perhaps f5
has to be done with quite a bit of care
and now bishop c2 and
i would probably put the bishop just
back on g2 i don't think this diagonal
will open anytime soon and i do think
the d5 pawn will be important at some
point if i retreat my bishop to c2 i'm
worried that this pawn could be
capturable at at some juncture not right
now but at some juncture it might be
capturable
uh i do think that i i would consider
the move rookie 8 in this position i i
just don't
see what's wrong with greed i don't know
if queen a4 works but
i would definitely check it out so
rookie 8 and then after e3 at that point
play at 5. yeah at this point i already
have to consider the possibilities of
queen f5 but as i said f5 is still in
the air maybe here bishop f5 or even the
move knight f5 because i think about
well knight of five blunders queen g4
after f5 how does queen h5 work by the
way probably queen h5 just checkmates me
in this position with with the rook on
f8 instead of e8 i had them with queen
eight and queen g6 but without this
possibility it's very likely i just get
made it and unfortunately that for you
that pawn on d5 stops you from um being
able to make a king walk right so it
takes on e4 queen g5 king f7 g7 is just
made that is just me this king is
definitely not escaping so already every
move that levon has to make now has to
be done with quite a bit of care because
white has very simple but difficult to
defend against threats at the moment
after bishop takes e4 you're looking at
both queen a4 and making sure that e3 is
not a decisive threat you kind of feel
e3's dangerous but you don't know how
dangerous
i will say also that there's a little
bit of hustle from fabiano caruana
playing this kind of position not going
back for the material queen a4 he no
doubt knew but probably knew that also
lavon looked at those kind of variations
and maybe felt comfortable in that kind
of position bobby said you know what
let's dance a little bit let's play
something a bit unclear i'll keep
the sacrifice material i'll let you keep
it anyway for now and then just build up
that pressure and force calculation in
this kind of time control time matters
look at that time expenditure from level
neurone he is a very responsible player
when it comes to time management very
rarely gets into supreme time trouble
even in rapid and it's taking him a long
time to respond to this natural position
it's a matter it's a mess totally
warranted in my opinion
this is exactly the kind of chess we
would like to see
lavon out of book after bishop takes e4
he is
under pressure even if you see a
computer might say black is better
doesn't matter no you get over the board
there is no such thing there's no such
thing as an evaluation it's unclear and
you're just trying to
cross the river
very difficult waters to threat on for
us engine analysis is always important
just in case of a blunder and such but
even the objective evaluation becomes
irrelevant at this kind of speed and the
faster it gets the more irrelevant it
becomes so we'll get the factual
analysis maybe once i might have been
winning yeah but so what when you're
under heavy pressure and lavon is indeed
under pressure he knows he has to start
off very strong another player who has
to start off strong is vishwanathan
anand and i really like this position
because i haven't seen this kind of
situation happen take a look here a
reverse gruntful by artemiev playing the
move d4 in this position and after cd4
knight takes d4 now bishop g7 typically
white is aiming for the c4 break or if
you have this kind of position you want
a c4 break e4 looks a bit difficult to
do after knight b3 knight c6 you start
wondering how is this move going to
happen he said i'm not going to play it
he's going to play knight c3 it's like
well your knight's blocking your c pawn
that's traditionally not correct so oh
maybe you're going to go for the e4
break he said nope i'm going to play
something completely different a4 in
this position and after castle's a5 just
constraining this side b6 is not so easy
to play right now so instead anand
played rookie 8 and after rook to e1
rook to b8 looking to maybe get this
pawn push going and i mean still we're
wondering about the c4 e4 break he said
uh nope i'm going to play the move
bishop to f4 hitting the bishop and
after e5 i hitting the rook excuse me
and after e5 bishop to g5 d4 knight to
e4 look at that big center all the
pressure already on the board this is a
wild one in the making as well
and we haven't taken a look at one game
we have kind of left it in the dark so
far one of our wild cards la quang liam
extremely strong in rapid and blitz
chess he's facing against shakira
mamadiro who's had kind of an up and
down year he has had some good results
the grand chester really didn't go his
way but he did win one of the legs of
the grand prix against maxine vasher
lagrave so
some good results here this came out of
an italian and it seems like black got
everything he wanted he has a strong
pawn center he kind of finishes
development only the bishop on c8 yet to
be developed white does have some good
squares this knight on b5 is very
annoying for the black side almost
forcing this bishop to retreat to b8
something that black doesn't
particularly want to do but
strategically it feels like white's
position is sound but not going anywhere
black has the domination in the center
with these pawns which eliminates this
kind of breaks you don't have c4 because
of d4 you don't have d4 because of e4
and i'm not really sure what lequing
liam's plan is if i simply hold on to
the center finish my development and
slowly improve my position what's your
plan of finishing your development so
you mentioned bishop b8 and then how are
you connecting your rooks in and
finishing your development are you
sticking
rook a6 at some point yes
i think this is a lovely resource when
you can do it rook to a6 bring it back
to the center via e6 if necessary you
can also swing it to the king side once
you move the knights this rook is kind
of
logically going to go to the e8 square
and it seems that we have a different
move but we have christian carrillo with
you guys
i want to draw your attention to one of
the more important games of the round of
course i'm talking about the one between
anish giri and wesley so because this
one uh from a practical perspective it
looks quite difficult for black and the
engine agrees with me in this position
white has pretty much everything but he
doesn't have that second weakness he has
the weakness on b6 he's going to try to
target that he's going to solidify his
position with a move such as f3 king b7
and i found a very interesting plan of
course with the help of the engine
bishop p3 which makes a lot of sense
king c7 i just want to sit with black of
course i cannot move my knight because
then i'm going to lose the b6 spawn i
just want to go king b7 king c7 and just
say what are what do you have what do
you have against that well this is what
i have i'm going to go g4 i'm going to
expand on the king side and try to
create force you to create that second
weakness h4 king c7 bishop d4 now i'm
starting to attack your pawns on on the
king side and of course e5 is the right
move in this position g6 is already a
blunder and after this one white is
winning with a simple plan i'm going to
go g5 solidify the pawn structure as it
is it looks quite healthy for black
because you cannot attack the pawns on
the light squares with the bishop but i
can do this i can put you in a suzwang
king b7 bishop g1 king c7 bishop h2
check and after king b7
bishop d6 suddenly you have no more
moves you cannot move the knight to f8
you cannot move the knight to ba you
cannot move the knight anywhere and if
you go king to a7 i'm going to penetrate
via c6 and this is just game over this
is looking bad for wesley it's going to
be a difficult defense but let's go back
to mauricio has some breaking news
indeed that would be a big result if
anish could defeat wesley so one of the
contenders for london for sure but take
a look at the double blunder that
happened in this game first of all
you've got this dragon set up it's
looking more positional for white now
he's got the b5 square looks like he's
got some control over the position you'd
expect black to make some kind of peace
move but the move e5 is just outrageous
to your eyes when you first see it you
think wait a minute you block the bishop
along the long diagonal and you weaken
your pawn on d6 is this positionally
founded well he played this move to
chase the knight out of the middle of
the board karjakin
missed a completely crushing blow the
move knight to c6 would have simply
cleared all the cobwebs in the position
a devastating move because after bishop
takes on c6 bishop takes c5 the d-pawn
is pinned it is under fire right now
it's going to go down and this position
is simply horrible for black suddenly
but one question after knight c6 bishop
c6 bishop c5 what in bishop b5 what is
the problem bishop takes on b5 is met by
the move bishop to b6 ah yeah that
probably was what was missed by both
players right
yes and now knight takes b5 and then a
pawn and everybody is golden so
this position
here bishop c6 bishop c5
sorry he didn't play knight c6 he played
the move knight back to c2 and gave his
opponent a chance queen to e7
car bob is still in the game as
took a chance with e5 i guess you got a
bluff sometimes it is a hustle out there
the problem is that even when your
opponent falls for the bluff and plays
the move knight c2 this move e5 makes
such a bad impression yeah that's what i
thought went right at first when maurice
was making faces at e5 i just thought he
was bemoaning the positional qualities i
was yeah
before we notice the tactical details
that it's a tactical blunder the move i
mean you're just not getting d5 in any
time soon if you could e5 is obviously
justified but at the moment i'm worried
that white is going to play at some
moment b4 forced me to take on before
and after i take with the knight i have
so many pieces eyeing this square on d5
you're never going to get that break in
this pawn is going to start rolling up
the board and as maurice mentioned this
bishop is just dead this seems like a
very clear advantage for the white side
even though
sergey didn't find the killing blow i
think he's clearly the driver's seat in
this position yeah usually when you want
to play e5 and the sicilian you don't
put your bishop on d7 yeah and even if
you do it's because you have a very
clear way of continuing
d5 is going to follow you're going to
play e5 right usually you've got d5
coming behind it at least f5 at least
something but you're just not getting
anything in this position it just looks
terrible let's jump back to the game
that's keeping our attention fabiano
carona against lavon ironian we have a
couple of moves at levon well he
validates me a little bit by playing the
move i had suggested rook e8 and very
quickly uh well maybe not that quickly
fabiano replied with him with queen d3
it does bring the queen closer to the
king side it's a bit of an awkward move
it does seem like e3 was a more natural
way to do things
but since bishop h7 is not really a
threat as far as i can see it's just a
check
it's a bit of a curiosity this move
queen d3 i'm not really sure about it
trying to play maybe um
to
introduce the idea of taking on h4 which
would bring a queen g3 check into the
position yeah
i can see this idea of gtx h4 happening
it just
doesn't feel like the correct move order
or queen b5
is also now introduced into the position
although we could have just played queen
before straight away so that doesn't
seem very distinct by the way fabi did
think for almost five minutes in this
movie we were away from this
five minutes it is a considerable thing
and then levon played the move queen d7
i actually quite liked this move
in some ways it gets rid of this threat
of queen b5 you were mentioning uh so
the bishop is pretty safe on b4 and it
also if necessary can jump to the king
side and defend that way you're
mentioning this idea of taking on h4 and
putting the queen on g3 well i got rid
of that because i can always counter
with queen g4 let's remember that black
is up a piece they'll be happy to
simplify the position i see that fabi
has played the move king h1 and that's a
cute little little move right there the
rook going to the g line that would get
me scared i mean it's not necessarily
true that you're going to die
immediately you can bring some things
over to that side but it's not easy he's
going to be chopping wood on g6 if
you're not careful now he just played
knight f5 spank that moved down i like
that
yeah you saw that f5
on the other hand the knight on f5 is
very committal it blocks a lot of your
pieces out of the action you can see the
queen on d7 and the bishop on c8 run out
of squares because of the this move
knight f5 i'm assuming this bishop has
to retreat from h6 i don't really think
um well f4 seems pretty safe to me f4
seems like the
because it doesn't block the g files
right i mean bishop g5 or bishop f4 look
like the most natural moves to me uh i
don't think i can make g takes h4 work i
run out of pieces if i give up my dark
squared bishop i assume that bishop f4
is the movement disposition
and this one is so
complicated as well it's not resolving
itself for black the bishop on c8 the
rook on a8 the bishop on b4 all out of
play white for the moment is essentially
up material because those pieces aren't
working but white hasn't figured out how
to break into the position and he wants
to just open up a line so his rush can
stream it along the g file if black
shuts that down then he has to somehow
build those white because he knows black
just needs a few moves gives him three
or four moves and black will start
exerting the influence of that extra
piece but for the moment white is in it
so it's a delicate moment in the game
that
what's going to happen next to keep the
pressure on black and keep him on his
back foot i think that's a very
important point maurice that you were
mentioning it's that
black's position doesn't get immediately
better and a lot of the times we see
that attacks when you sacrifice a piece
you're under the clock you have a few
moves to make that initiative work or
that piece is going to manifest itself
in a powerful way over the board but in
this position the king safety is just a
permanent weakness here for black so
even if you do have a free couple of
moves as uh le honoring in this position
i don't think it's as easy to untangle
this position especially after the move
knight f5 because now your pieces as you
mentioned are not coming out as swiftly
and that's perhaps why fabi takes his
time to put the king on h1 saying yes
you're up a piece and yes i should be
against the clock to actually create
threats but since your pieces are so
tangled up on the queen side on the
knight on f5 i'm going to take my time
to bring my last few pieces which are
the rooks into the battle and he has
chosen the bishop g5 tough choice there
because the nice thing about bishop g5
we look at the f6 square yes we put
pressure on h4
the negative that the g-file is now
interfered with and
fabi decided to go for that move after a
couple of minutes think i mean he
doesn't have all day right but it does
feel like once the bishop comes to f6
that black's position is extremely
dangerous because normally a bishop on
f6 you can kick it out in many ways you
can attack with a queen or rook and
bishop something but here the bishop on
f6 is untouchable there is no square
from which i can target this bishop kick
it out of the board especially
specifically the f6 square and safeguard
my king once the bishop's there i just
don't see how to remove it i'm even
thinking of just throwing away my pawn
on the f7 square playing move f6 so that
i have a little bit of room on the queen
side for my pieces
you're accurate to a fault the move the
move f6 is necessary right now wow
absolutely necessary in order to get any
kind of coordination because he's about
to get stepped on his queen is tethered
to this night the bishop is tethered
nothing can move nothing it doesn't
matter what's happening over here your
pieces are frozen and it's white who's
preparing g4 ideas rook g1 ideas
capturing on h4 ideas so black has to
hurry up it turns out the only way to
play he could also sacrifice right now
rookie four another bout of desperation
where he'd be a little worse or he'd be
clearly worse though not totally lost
but this line bishop takes f6 queen
eight seven is actually better for black
according to the engines oh that's a
very beautiful trick i mean what an
amazing idea because now the rookie
fourth threat with knight g3 and picking
off the bishop comes into play so
actually after f6 you can't take on f6
so lavon has to find this this is the
one flaw of the bishop to g5 move that
this f6 idea is possible will lavone
find it because his other chances look
absolutely grim yeah i'm also looking
for ideas in this line to
get rid of my bishop on b4 play bishop
d2 try to trade off the bishop for the
the bishop on e4 yeah i think this
weakness of the bishop on b4 is why the
entire line can be played for white
because if the bishop was for example an
f8 i think white could resign i mean
you're just down a piece for nothing but
the bishop on before is never getting to
the defense it takes so long for this
bishop to come back and it's just this
concept of one misplaced piece allowing
the entire variation to exist and i love
the move f6 queen h7 that is such a
beautiful way of getting rid of your
problems this queen on h7 exerting the
pressure on the e4 bishop because the
king's on h1 there is this knight g3
check type of tricks and yeah let's show
it so for instance if a3 hears well i
think the natural move is to take on h4
right because you would like to open uh
the rook on g1 but unfortunately i think
i can just take on e4 in this position
and it doesn't matter if i throw in rook
g1 and i just move my king he found it
and he did find f6 yes the point is that
if queen e4 i have knight g3 check i
have to take the knight and of course
this queen is just completely hanging
levon aronian is the one who told me he
said the one thing about a strong player
is this if you give a strong player a
situation where there are lots of moves
lots of good interesting possibilities
it's possible to screw up the position
but if you give them a position where
there's one move you you don't have any
real choice because your position is
terrible you just defined a move and
somebody says look it's the moment you
need to find something that they will
invariably find it he's the one who
keyed me in on that idea that strong
players i don't care how difficult the
move just make sure it's only one so
they have to look at plenty of them and
here he goes he finds the one key move
f6 and now the position is really turned
around because the queen is able to
shift and reorganize itself with tempo
in this position on the bishop that's
why bishop f4 was better and now f6
gains that critical tempo so the queen
can unravel the entire position for
black now it is an important pawn once i
take on f6 queen h7 as long as i protect
myself from your trick of rook takes c4
i think the precision is still very
murky because you don't have any other
threats that i can see i could play
perhaps rook g1 does that
you're actually work
six queen eight seven and i want
to get to your king while defending from
the threads so i was kind of wondering
if i can play the move rook g one
interesting probably yeah so you were
gonna thank god yeah the idea is that if
you take on e4 i can take on e4 knight
takes g3 check
and i can retake with chuck i love it so
that and you cannot take on g well you
have to take on g3 but that loses of
course because queen e8 is actually
checkmate
so um
[Music]
so that also loses for black so at this
point i'm wondering if i can instead
play pawn takes g3 but that looks a
little weird king f8 getting off the
discovery is just the move renewing all
the threats and it's still back to the
rookie iv concept in the knight g3 move
and this is this is a serious
position for
yeah it's a weird position because i
feel like even after bishop f3 i will
have ideas of simply playing e4 kick out
your knight i still have a lot of pawns
material balance is three pawns for a
piece so it's not
like five has no chances in this
position but it is a very strange kind
of i'll show you a crazy crazy position
here's a crazy line queen g6 in this
position here look at that queen g6
attacking the bishop okay
and now your bishop is just hanging it's
well it's kind of trapped it's kind of
trapped bishop h8 looks
pretty weird yeah but the problem is i'm
not playing this move
the problem here is uh bishop takes h4
he's bent by knight takes on h4 pawn
takes and then queen takes on d3 and
look at these white pawns
have you seen any pawns worse than these
in your life no this is pretty
disgusting probably not and the bishop
is totally and the bishop is totally
saying black is fine you can argue um i
have three is it three how many points
is i i have four pawns you can argue the
widest of materials
no this looks great for black i think f6
is a very powerful move uh fabi's
starting to think uh should i take this
pawn i'm not sure he has a choice though
uh bishop f4 just seems like a worse
version of the previous move and still
allows queen h7 i don't see the big
difference
i i still think he has to take the pawn
on f6 if he wants to continue the attack
bishop iv feels like too much of a
concession perhaps we should uh go
around some of the other games well we
should look at this game that was a
horror ball this move e5 and after
what did we have a queen e7 sighting
back here
yes he didn't play the knight c6
knockout punch but he knows he's got the
great position your bishop on g7 will be
bad forever the pawn on d6 it ain't
going nowhere this one is on lockdown so
he just played slowly with rook a3 and
as you mentioned alejandro b4 now we've
got everything controlled c3 is covered
by the rook so this knight has no
trickery against his position a takes
knight takes and d5 is just smelling
rosie and so he decided to play d5
himself look at the tactics along this
long diagonal because of the knight and
the rook but it turns out after takes
takes takes takes and takes there's
nothing for you to do that's going to
hurt him this pawn has just suddenly
become too powerful even if you want an
exchange with a discovery like 94 which
is
actually doesn't look like you win
anything after queen a2 so e4 played now
just rook back e takes f3 this is the
position looks a little bit wild but the
engines give g takes and this pass pawn
this pass pawn two bishops and anchored
peace black has released his position
but he is completely busted
and we're gonna go to budapest with
christian who wants to jump in
we're here in bucharest maurice not
budapest
but of course i want to talk about the
same game that you were mentioning the
one between um karjakin and korobov
because korobov actually missed a huge
chance and you were mentioning after b4
the final position
still lingers around the d5 square the
two bishops and white is just being
dominant but in this position black had
this move knight c takes e4 an
incredible sacrifice now if you take
with the f pawn which looks very normal
i'm going to take a takes b4 knight
takes b4 you have a lot of control over
the d5 square but you're also very
tangled and i'm going to go d5 this
queen is going to attack the knight on
b4 you cannot move the knight on b4
because you're going to lose the rook on
a3 i also have a second threat and that
is to play the move d4 and that is just
a fork you're going to lose in one piece
so the position explodes actually black
is better in this position white after
knight xc4 he had to recapture with the
knight but after bishop takes e4 f64
knight takes e4 to be honest from a
practical point of view i prefer black
of course the engine still give white a
slight edge
nevertheless this position looks wild
and is definitely preferable to the one
that they have in the game after queen
e2 i can take on b4 knight xb4 play d5
sorry
after queen e2 in this position i can
play d5 first open up my queen have a
nice center have a beautiful knight on
e4 ready to jump to c3 the position is
just wild and black would have had a
great chance to strike back and find
counterplay
well thank you christian but there is
one game that's capturing our attention
jen this game between artemyev and anand
has exploded
we left it off more or less in this
position as we can take a look at the
board this reversed fianchetto groove
field that we had and in this position
vishy played the move b6 now when i play
v6 here it's just a blunder i've learned
in the exchange when it's vision it's a
deep sacrifice knight takes f6 bishop
takes f6 bishop takes c6 and there's no
really decent move for the rook
because if i capture on g5 of course
after bishop takes c8 i mean i'm still
down the exchange but once you analyze
the position it's not just the material
balance you see this pair of bishops is
monstrous the spot on d4 really hinders
white's position and these rooks for the
moment are just not doing anything vishy
thought this is my chance to get huge
compensation and play for the win and i
love that he's done it after the move h4
he brought back his bishop to h6 and
artemis starts trying to break out of
the position because he's so contained
at the moment by the pawn structure and
the bishops that he needs to give the
rooks this activity but after c3 fishy
said not so easy rook c8 and now you
cannot take on d4 because bishop c2 not
only forks the queen and the knight it
actually just traps the queen on the d1
square for this reason knight d2 was
played a little bit of an awkward move
but the point is that after e4 which was
played on images i love that movie
yeah e4 was absolutely great let me just
go back to this position e4 putting down
the pressure e3 on the works so much
compensation here for the former world
champion knight f1 pawn takes c3 e3
being played weakening that king on g1
queen a4 it's a little bit of a loose
move but it's difficult to find moves
here in the position for artemis look at
that time situation by the way two
minutes for the young russian player and
the problem is we just tried to take off
one of the bishops like knight e3 and
kim bell you to take on e3 and you'll do
so happily as um you're in you're you're
just going to um invade with the bishop
and the queen it's just completely
weakened i mean you're going to kind of
survive this you know let me have says
let me just put my queen out there but
bishop d7 of course i don't want to
trade my queens when i have such a huge
attack queen d4 the queen centralized
congratulations but it has to go back to
f2 i pick up a pawn now it's a pawn for
the pair of bishops a huge attack the
king on g1 feeling very unsafe the move
rook d1 was played i think we have a
couple of moves no bishop ffa was played
by anan threatening bishop c5 now what a
masterpiece this is a mess this is a
masterpiece masterpiece let's get it
clear this game is astonishing watching
this it looks like uh over the board
game the sacrifices that he made to get
to this ex this exchange stack by anan
this is simply gorgeous it's a gorgeous
game
as a
player
you look at it and you say who's playing
this this is vishy at his finest just an
incredible start for him he's
demolishing her and look at artemyev
with just one and a half minutes on his
clock compared to 16 plus for vichy if
she has not only been playing brilliant
chess but he's been doing it fast
alejandro i mean are you guys in shock i
mean i'm in shock it's a beautiful way
of sacrificing the exchange because
normally you sacrifice for the exchange
for one pawn and you say i have enough
but fully sacrifice the exchange that's
difficult in a position that just looks
like it's sitting there it's like wow
but he was able to assess that he had
complete dominance in the position we
saw magnus carson play a4 a5 a6 against
wesley so in that
fischer random that turned out to be not
so good and now we see this lone pawn
sitting on a6 a future victim in this
position as well uh just
absolute master class of rapid chess
played here and mr b5 just just
attacking that pawn and that's what's so
beautiful about that vichy down in
exchange but playing on both sides of
the board the pressure's just not going
away and that's the beauty about this
pair of bishops the king is so
permanently unsafe on h2 that i can take
my time and improve myself also on the
queen side this knight on f1 is just not
going to participate in any attacking
way it still needs to get to e3 and to
d5 before it does anything it's just a
little bit too slow and the bishops are
just controlling the entire board and
that pawn just got snapped off bishop
takes a6 played by vichy yeah not
surprising now we have equal material uh
the exchange for two pawns but equal i'm
actually surprised that he took the pawn
and tell you the truth i thought he he
wouldn't give the rooks any chance
rookie one just played in the position
but still i think if it was a slow game
he finds a way to continue the attack
but playing under pressure
it's probably just better to take the
material keep your positional trumps and
make him think well but the also the
thing is when you have all that extra
time on the clock if you could just
spend three minutes right there and find
the kind of real squeeze move that
forces him to look at the board this one
got a quick rook a1 and of course he's
dead anyway so maybe we're just
splitting hairs but vishy is still
playing beautiful chest lots of time on
the clock artemia is going to have to
show us something what an introduction
to the grandchester where you come in
and you get your teeth rattled
immediately by the way after all indeed
bishop bishop e2 not on tap because of
her k2 so what do you think of issues
going to play in this exact position
there's a couple of tempting moves in
this position i mean if i have time to
calculate if bishop b7 actually works
because i'm very tempted to make this
battery kind of function bishop 7 queen
c6 of course i give the chance of bishop
b7 and rook takes a seven so i'm not
really sure if i do want to give up my
pawn
but b7 was he didn't play mission pc so
your thought is that after rook a7 queen
c6 you're just gonna
play rook b7 yeah without calculating
too much i kind of assumed that between
the moves bishop d6 and the threat of
checkmate on the diagonal and the fact
that you don't want to weaken your
second rank by playing e4 something
should win i don't have to calculate it
something should this is terrible it
that's awful everything is in black's
favor this is a completely busted
position he should take this one home a
position that we should also remember
this one take a look at what's going on
after f6 fabi decided i see all the
threats i can't take on f6 let me take
on h4 but here came queen 87 and he's
really regretting putting that bishop on
g5 now he played rook to g1 and then the
calm cool bishop to d7 saying i am
unraveling now remember when black was
stuck a bishop on c8 queen on d7 he
couldn't figure out how he was going to
unleash anything here white playing for
the initiative now it's all black and
after queen to f3
rook takes on e4 hasn't been played
queen takes
well yes queen takes played on e4 as
well now and there's no knight g3 but
now the move rook to e8 on the board as
he continues this attack
incredible position but what's happening
here exactly queen g4 check king f7 and
again there's no way to really change
this construction on this side of the
board there's some kind of threats of
rook g8 there's also something there's
actually a rookie four that's back in
the position in this game i mean just
absolutely pure attack by black all
these chances are favoring black in this
position bobby in real trouble well
those rooks just look so useless uh it
doesn't matter that you're up any kind
of material we've got just 10 seconds
left for vladislav as he suffers against
vichyanan
it's game over i mean
and he almost did just lose on time is
there any problem with taking on e3
because there's no mate there's no i'm
actually bishop i'm not even sure which
one the fastest win is there must be
more than one wave
he's taking away that's resignation
though oh he's taking on b7 yeah but i
think i have both rook takes g3 and
bishop to hg3 both work i think
and now she's going to continue along
this line very forcing taking with check
and things are hanging uh if queen takes
on b7 looks like you can just resign
right someone takes seven you're up your
rook is hanging on e1 he'll just resign
after queen b7 there's just down too
much material
there's no perpetual right let's just
show that real quick that queen takes e3
bishop takes c1
there is no queen eight and queen e5 i
have f6 okay this is the last gasp but
after rookie five that's it and now the
rook solid and he resigns what a game
excellent game by this year not a way to
start the tournament
and the first winner of the super bed
vishyana and
um drawing first bud with black against
a very promising wild card and i'm
wondering if the second blood will be
drawn by anish giri i think his position
is completely winning we had seen
christian demonstrate exactly the
winning technique for that end game and
i think he's going straight for it
black seems to be almost if not already
zugzwang in the position that we have on
the board between geary and wesley so
you can see that this knight on d7 is
pretty much stuck and unfortunately
for black you have to make a move at
some point
if you could just maintain the fortress
and not make a move i don't see how
white makes any progress but you are
running out of moves this knight on d7
cannot move because the bottom b6 is
just
needs defense but you're kind of stuck
moving the king the king cannot go to a7
because of the penetration on c6 it's
also a5 to watch out for you also have
to watch out for a5 so the only uh
kind of decent move that you have at
this point is the move king c7 but again
i can try to keep the zook swung up
bishop d4 you have to move the king
again you cannot move the knight you
cannot move a pawn so you have to play
king b7 and the question is if i have a
great way of improving my position where
do i want to situate my bishop so that
this is a winning position i'm trying to
get it to d6 but then you have king a7
again i have a couple of ideas i was
wondering if i could put my king my
bishop on d8 but i have to time this
appropriately
let's try to win this end game
there should be a win i just don't king
c7 has been played by the one yeah it
does feel like king c7 was the only move
and bishop i'm pretty sure he's going to
go to yeah it looks like he's pointed
towards that square bishop d4 he was
about to touch the bishop there so you
were you were saying you wanted to stick
your bishop on d8 right right if this
bishop gets to the end i think the way
christian demonstrated you're just dead
lost because you actually take control
of the c7 square from the king and that
means that the king cannot move anymore
and you will be zug's one so bishop t4
king b7 bishop f6 king c7 yeah and he
might be and then bishop e7 so i see
what he's doing he's playing bishop f2
first
so that on king b7 then i think i played
bishop d4 king c7 and here i think i can
play can i play bishop f6 here where
you're looking at bishop f6 knight yeah
sure right yeah yeah
king d7 we're gonna be too fast yeah
this is just a winning end game and if
you put the king on b7 i'll play bishop
d8 as i intended the only question would
be what if i play against knight c5 but
i think i have a5 in this position
looks good looks pretty good to me so
you have to go you have to go knight at
fade but i'm assuming there's a win here
and gary looks confident he's just
flying through now with the moves and
here we have the position after
c7 he needs to find this move and it
looks like bishop f6 will be all she
wrote wesley so having tasted the blood
of magnus carlsen right winning
beautifully in oslo
but you know what chess is a fickle game
anything could happen in your very next
game you're only as good as your last
victory
and we have christian with our first
winner in super bet rapid and blitz of
isian on
of course i'm here with five-time world
champion viswanathan
who just simply destroyed vladimir
temiev from what looked like a very very
strange uh
and loose opening from white we should
take us through the game and explain to
us what you think are the critical
moments
well
so
i was trying to improve slightly on my
game with hikaru but
larislav went first a four castles a5
hadn't really entered my thing but if
you realize this becomes like e3
grunfeld yep so
in fact just uh colors reversed
and
i think there as well black sometimes
plays a5
and i spent a few minutes trying to
understand the subtleties and i realized
it's too much work to do over the board
and i just tried to make some moves
and here i must say i initially just
miscalculated
i mean i thought this would be quite
safe but
i felt either 92 or maybe knight c5 and
i'm under some pressure so i wasn't
completely happy with what i did and
then if that is the case then instead of
rook b8 i should play baby head 6 and
just take away the square were you
expecting him to take the the exchange
well by this stage i stopped expecting
something and i just thought i'll play
bishop f5 because you know i have to do
it and then we'll see what he does and
if he goes knight c5 i was going to play
b6 actually okay and offer the exchange
again take stakes so if he does that i
was going to play b6 and i mean i didn't
see anything shattering but i was wish
we have to interrupt you because there's
some results coming in but thank you
very much for joining us maybe stay for
a second congratulations and let's go to
uh the other games and see exactly
what's happening
thank you
of course to vichy and christian and
what's blowing up on the board well
we've got to go to the fabiano carbon
against live on aronian game
everything that black wanted in that
position he has got the king is finally
safe on f7 the knight on e3 is a monster
that bishop has retreated back to b6
he's up material he's just taken on d5
this looks horrible not to mention the
time situation yeah this is all levon
aronian destroying fabi from a very
murky position for sure but this
resource f6 shook
the american player and at the moment i
just don't think he's going to survive
this way too much going on for black in
this position yeah so many trumps as you
mentioned
may i jump in though right even though
he is definitely lost
there was a move missed and
you know when you you don't play the top
move and we saw it we see it happening
in the karjakin game where he was
completely winning but now he's in a
very murky position against korabov you
can't just say i'm better so what i'll
play any old move these players are
fighters this position here queen d5 was
not the optimal move to play actually he
had a killer blow in the move bishop to
g4 what a move to find the threat of
taking on f3 or mating and of course you
can't capture here because now queen d5
is a knockout punch so this was possible
instead he took on d5 to move g4 came
back into the game he's still definitely
worse here now the move c6 and now g5 on
the board and keeping things closed with
f5 this is a position to win bishop back
to f2 still all
in black's control but he didn't miss
the most decisive blow will it be
that he he doesn't win because of it his
position looks so good so delicious for
black right now that it's hard to
imagine
no this looks terrible i think from a
practical point of view it's very
difficult to play for the white side
and we have christian with a quick
thought
huge breakthrough for uh for uh anish
geary who is just simply winning wesley
played the move h6 because he was in
suswan and now anish had this amazing
blow bishop to d8 check i'm going to
sacrifice the bishop to distract the
king from the defense of the pawn on b6
king takes d8 now i'm going to take on
h6 the knight has to go to f6 to stop me
from pushing my pawn to h7 and promoting
and now i'm just simply going to take
the other pawn then i'm going to start
pushing my a pawn down the board and
this is just simply winning there's
nothing you can do the knight cannot
split uh into two defenses on the king's
side and on the queen side this is just
simply game over if he sees bishop v8
and he has played it i think this is
just going to be resigned anytime soon
what an amazing technical masterpiece by
anish giri i love bishop d.a that is one
to show your students if you're telling
them about the power of the outside past
plot how about two outside past fonts
one game that's curious to me is this
game between karjakin and korobov
because maurice had mentioned it became
murky i was wondering how did it become
murky but it was this position that i'm
i'm trying to see it over and over again
trying to understand
how karaki decided that after queen bee
bishop a6 queen b3 you can see that his
rook on d1 is hanging and normally you
move it i'm assuming that rook d2 is a
good move in this position perhaps
actually the other rook that's the other
rook then maybe it's so a little bit
difficult because you do want to keep
that defense on the pattern a5 but he's
not taking it because of the pin on the
on the line so he would actually keep it
i understand but it just feels unnatural
to move the rook from the a file i think
because that is such a strong pass pawn
that perhaps he decided well let's just
take on b7 and push it to the end but
the problem is that when you give up
this exchange with check you give a
couple of options of black returning
this material with rook takes b7 at some
point
and this is exactly what happened
now material is even this part is not
strong enough to really create that much
trouble and even after the move queen c6
this king is quite exposed i'd still
rather be white but i'm not really sure
by how much as we see anish geary has
won his game was to resign after the
beautiful bishop dna check a nice little
finesse to finish that game and hey that
one percent has gone up a little bit
starting with the win
it was really a classy game though this
is the kind of game that you would this
one has ended it looks like in a draw
between these two players we hadn't
followed this too much because there was
a little bit of action uh in the game
but still was keeping well within bounds
but i gotta say two players who have
played really well really consistently
so far are indeed
a beautiful game sacrificing the
exchange the way he did that's a
high-class kind of chess game and anish
giri who didn't play for much it looked
like and we were saying she looks draw
looks draw but you know anishi is the
master of the draw as everyone calls him
he knows the difference between a draw
and an edge that could possibly win him
the game and that bishop proved to be
superior to the knight in the end that's
right
and we still have two games remaining as
lavon
putting the moves on fabi well
uh you were just uh
updating us on kayaking and keraba yeah
this end game must be a draw with the
blockade the black house on the d6
square
he karjakin plays bishop h6 hoping that
this spin on the background does
something but that's the problem the
king on g2 is a little bit too exposed
after queenie to check this must be some
sort of perpetual i think this will end
in a draw
momentarily
what a fun round and you know it's
always amazing when you start the first
round of the rapid with a game that very
well might be the game of the tournament
and it's not a great start for a couple
of the people that need to win this
tournament not just win a couple games
they need to win the tournament karjakin
he had it in the bag in my opinion
against core above both strategically
after the movie five and tactically
after the movie five but this will end
in a disappointing draw and five is just
getting
outplayed and here are the where they
are claiming a draw claiming a draw but
okay there's no real need threefold is
obvious at this point we assume an
arbiter is on hand to finish the game
one would assume so
as we can just move to the fabiano game
well let's take a look at what's going
on this knight is cemented on e3 the
king on g7 is extremely safe
i mean bearing an
awful blunder this just has to be game
over more food just snap some lunch on
d4
has been taken oh this is although it
looks like the engines are not happy
when when you got too materialistic here
but still actually the move rook d1 is a
bit annoying
and he has been played rook to d1 yeah
actually
i really didn't like bishop takes d4
perhaps i'm missing something
and that has complicated matters this is
his only chance hoping that his
opponents lose his focus as that move
rook d1 has been played however it looks
like bishop h3 according to the hinges
is a monster move
right now
uh
because you want to play bishop h3 and
g5 yeah perhaps first bishop g2 to force
the king to g1 and then i will take on
g5 and some discovery chuck master in
the game after that of course do not
take the rook on d1
because i can take back on d1 and this
bishop will be lost actually even this
even this after rookie two looks like
two yeah yeah you just don't have to be
afraid of any discovery because checker
can just move my king i think even to g6
looks fine and you just can't get to the
king in any way your pieces are not
coordinated there's no discovery with
the bishop because the rook is on pre
and okay this is going to get
[Music]
so you can't even take the rook
yeah yeah decided he's taking the rook
well that's pretty bad position when you
can take the rook and play bishop c5
another way of accentuating the
desperation that is white's position
multiple ways to win and lavon is just
confident this really will virtually put
a nail in the coffin of fabiana caruana
to lose immediately right out the gate
in a rapid game that's two points this
is not what you want obviously to have
happen with lavon but if you're a lavon
fan this is amazing exactly another
great game by lavon the players that
we're looking at lavon
we mentioned christian mentioned lavonne
and anand playing beautiful chess we
mentioned there are three players that
you're looking at wesley soldo took it
on the chain went down in this round
queen and four played by the way but now
we can just drop back the queen to e6
and everything is defended and we're up
a piece right i mean
i think and indeed that is what happened
between
bishop c5 prolonging the suffering at
the moment you're down a piece no reason
to play on no reason
both victories with black anand and
aronian those are the guys that we're
looking at i think those were dominant
performances
great games absolutely great games this
boats really well for their chances for
london although it took a mistake it
took that move bishop g5 by fabi that
was a real mistake but
but since a mistake since the move
bishop g5 was played yeah because after
f6
i understand but but after that move
let's just say after that move levana's
played like a total genius yes but he
found f6 pure defense and then just like
a train has completely run over fabiano
since that moment i mean hats off this
was a great game by levon neroni and
just understood the position better than
fabi that move f6 changed everything it
put fabi on the back foot he didn't know
how to react put the bishop awkwardly on
h4
and then he just did not improve his
position
nah he was in big trouble after that
there were some crazy lines he could
have taken and put his bishop on e5 some
bizarre computer lines you have to find
to save that position but as we said the
beautiful play by the black with the
black pieces players looking confident
we're always looking for the players who
are in form right now what anand just
did
i mean he better not keep playing like
that
how do you stop a player that plays
chess like that that was insane just
intuitively beautiful exchange sacrifice
and oh somebody stopped this one because
look at that queen only three the extra
fish in there can he throw a wide flash
i mean this is throw in the towel
christian come on this is just down a
piece there's no reason to play well
that last move queen f5 does tickle a
queen of six
check thread although it is the one and
only threat in the position right so is
rookies
simple and shuts everything down forever
yeah
that looks just
like an empty threat and he's decided to
just back his queen up and chase the
queen
over to the king side he's got to play
queen g4
and now queen d4 and that c pawn can
push
what's the time situation how bad is it
that's why he's still playing he has so
little time he doesn't have time to
resign
that's what the increment is for
we didn't see that a lot
yeah but okay this
doesn't really deserve any more time
i mean there's no threat right after
queen f5 i can play c3 i can play rookie
three
we've seen strange things happen in
rapid chess to be sure so lavon has less
he is at 37 seconds and not playing very
confidently displaying great technique
he's let go of the rope a little bit has
lavone looking around wondering what he
should do this move h4h5 might creep in
look at that repeating moves and now
finally advancing the pawn to c3
kind of hard to imagine how you deal
with that but here comes the h-pawn as
we mentioned well there's the
counter-play h5 h6 g6 and you'll promote
those spots eventually maybe not this
life but eventually
well now there's this potential of the
c1 queens and then takes on e2 with
check i think the other way around and
he'll break into the position so he
moved the king away yeah because the
other way around was stronger you played
take on e2 first
aha and then and then continue but now
there's a bishop d7 right here to look
for and here it is bishop d7 trapping
the queen and finally forcing
resignation right
nice game lavon oronion
win with black that brings a number of
decisive games in this round to three
as anand oronyan and gary are all tied
for the lead a great way to start in
bucharest for sure i just love the way
anand and aronian played in this round
they showed that they want to be there
in london that they're not afraid to
take the risks necessary to be their
opponents and honestly they made their
opponents look bad artemia has had such
a year he's played such great chess and
he just looked like he got massacred out
of the gates there by anand that's one
to take a closer look at guys i mean to
look at it slowly because some
phenomenal attacking moves by on and
then another great game anish giri that
instructive end game technique great
game bishop overnight power of the
outside past pawns and throw in a sweet
little tactic
to
win most gracefully i think that bishop
d8 is just the nice little detail that
makes you really satisfied with your
game like you played a nice one but that
little detail just
nailed the coffin but i really like you
were mentioning the anon game just the
way that he was able to evaluate this
position to me is is amazing
because if you give white one more move
a couple more moves you can start
thinking it is an exchange you do manage
to untangle imagine you put the knight
on e3 or if the knight even gets to d5
that's the dream that you get a dream
the knight to d5 the queen to d4 you
support it with c4 put a rook on d1 i
mean you're just you're just kind of
naturally making some moves but you just
don't get there and are not evaluated
this perfectly but of course we have
another winner with christian kirili
krilla right from bucharest
yes we're here with anish giri of course
we have we've had some tactical battles
but this one was an endgame masterpiece
on anisha take us through the game was
this preparation from the beginning till
the end
not exactly but of course fortunately
unlike the chess 960 you are able to
prepare like a couple moves here so i
was i was aware of the first few moves
and this position occurred
on numerous occasions uh all the way
until uh yeah like the this light piece
end game has been played before even
wesley had a game in the isle of man
here i think uh
but i i was just curious um if he's
going to handle it very precisely
because in that game after 96 the point
when ke4 and after f5 check um there
were some forced uh issues and
potentially the black king yeah the king
came very fast and here the difference
is that
the point is that if f5 the knight d4
is important and then
if i take take there is an illusion that
this is sort of a fortress but it's not
because i go considering beforehand pick
it up so the knight would have to switch
to c6 but he cannot do all at once
no no not yet no and the king also not
in time yet so king of 8 is a better
move and then after 94 well we got this
end game i'm not sure
uh i think the point of this endgame is
that basically if the king was on c6 it
must be a fortress item because knight
has enough squares and it comes back to
d7 and you've got let's say you put upon
g6 all pawns on the light squares
optically it looks very close to
equality but it just doesn't get there
yeah the thing is if it doesn't get to
um c6 then uh it is much more
interesting because
i cannot win by super song because he
goes qmp7 b7 c7 endlessly with bishop on
e3 but i do have an idea that once the
king is on b7 i can plant a bishop on d6
and having a pawn on g5 it is a two song
so you knew all this
um
well to be
at honest
today but i think the position of bishop
on this example on g5
i sort of was
aware of the possibility it's
interesting because the engine is
showing already quite a clear advantage
for a wipe but it doesn't it doesn't
look like much
well it's all about the it's all about
the you know bishop against knight is
all about the supersong positions if
you've got notes song as a draw if
you've got a two song you win so the
engine's evaluation actually very
confusing i see it says like 1.1 i don't
know if it means winning or drone it's
to be analyzed further what is very uh
critical is okay let's say i do manage
to push even the pawn to g5 suppose but
the question of course is okay let's say
if you would put this position
i would guess this is some sort of a
sustan position i mean you have some
pawn moves but probably they will you'll
run out of them but the question of
course is what happens after e5 and uh i
was really thinking about various
versions of this position during the
game
i think what i actually checked once a
long time ago
is that the endgame is not an easy draw
i'm not sure if i checked if it's
winning uh or if it's drawn i don't
remember but i think yeah this here is a
question you know i have lots of
interesting ideas
maybe like in the game you know push the
h pawn then go f4 e4 and put the bishop
on f6
like in the game because here
it's a sort of suksank and it's very
funded after h5 which is
a little more tenacious than h6 because
i don't have the check i go back
and i do exactly the same exactly the
same thing
and we sort of
go back to square one here and this is
probably a tsuku song because can you
actually explain why uh the move a4 is
so important
and it's a good question there were i
mean knight c5 i've got a5 i think so
for for example yes and um
uh otherwise here i think he runs out of
moose so
maybe the toughest is is this but then i
think
i think this is a this is a swank
and uh it's actually mutual took some
because i'm also
out of moves probably
but yeah it's important that it's him
but even even if you
lose this position i think it should
still be winning i don't think something
really can kiss yourself oh no no no no
no you've got 98 as well
you've got it some point knight to b8
yeah
and now you get the knight to cc yeah
the problem with this position let's say
you would be right if i would have if
you would have to look himself but
you've got this move knight b8 to c6 and
knight is much better there because
you've got 97 check as well or knight on
a6 we've got knight c7 so that would be
simply a draw
so it is actually important that here
i'm winning move move by move but after
h6
i was thinking first to do the same but
then he will trade a gag and then he
trade e5 and all the pawns are traded
and there are some drawing chances but
in fact they are not supported this
movie just wins on the spot because i've
got you know the knight is bad against
the corner pawns the side pawns but
we've got two you should know you got
two of them of course uh beautiful game
congratulations on it we'll let you go
and prepare for the next one thank you
but thank you for the stopping by thanks
guys back to you
thank you and let's take a look at our
standings as we have three players at
the top of the table with those
fat two points for winning a rapping
game lavon anish and vichy
all tied for first
meanwhile of course we have four players
withdrawals and a little typo there at
the end we'll get that fixed uh with two
hundred percent
he might have felt like he lost two
games in fact to relegate him to the
bottom because that game that anahan hit
him i mean i i remember losing a game a
long time ago to mark gin
wesley's the one who's missing by the
way
mark mark ginsburg uh beat me in a blitz
game in the park in central park in
washington square park from my famous
video where i won against a hustler but
i remember playing against mark ginsburg
and i lost i was not even than i am yet
and i lost this blitz game where i was
completely winning he tricked me and he
won the game and vinnie livermore who
was played by lawrence fishberg in the
movie searching for bobby fischer he was
standing there when i lost the game and
he said one is good for two and i lost
the next one also he was right
psychologically that blow really hurts
will artemia come back after taking out
of the chin in this game will fabi come
back after taking on the chin in this
game as well here is a moment guys you
know this is one you just relish you
look at these types of games but the the
point we were talking about is how does
black unravel this position looks
terrible how do you figure it out well
the way to do it is by playing f6 and
queen 87 if you can pull those moves
together you get away well first bishop
f4 don't play bishop g5 because he wants
to play f6 anyway and now take a look at
what the engine suggests here the mo
this move
hard to find really hard to find he
wants to play queen eight seven how do
you play prophylactically as the late
mark doveretsky would say retreat the
bishop to f3 get it off of this e4
square for one so it's not under threat
and now the move queen 87 can we get it
in no because of this beautiful queen b5
suddenly hitting the rook and the bishop
those are world-class moves to find you
need time on the clock to be able to
find moves like that fabi did not find
it played simplistically and got a run
over we're going to jump back to
bucharest for the winner of this game
who is standing by with christian
what an incredible game by leveronian
that first of all congratulations that
was super exciting take us through the
game were you aware of this please
sacrifice with knight h4
yeah well uh i think i already played it
maybe three years ago
this is some old prep
which i think
i worked on
for yeah actually four years ago for the
kind of days
or maybe five i don't know anyway uh
yeah this position is uh more or less uh
kind of a tabia there are zillions of
options for white and black moves
earlier
uh but what the
fabi did is also very interesting
uh this uh
the point of this solo position is that
it seems that queen e4 is very strong
but in fact black is doing fine after
bishop d2 wow it's uh the bishop comes
back the bishop is actually lost on f8
so yeah
so
therefore he played bishop before rookie
queen d3 was an interesting move i i
wasn't sure about rookie 8 but i thought
oh what the heck i i analyzed during the
game this
and i thought so you were out of uh home
cook preparation yeah yeah mission
before i was not aware and i thought
here i have many options after a b okay
queen f6 is very interesting because
bishop e3 is very risky
takes on g3 and then
but also rookie 2 should guarantee me
a decent position
so yeah queen d3 was uh
most principled uh 27 king h1 this is
all very natural
uh knight f5 i probably have to play
and here yeah i saw this f6 idea and uh
i somehow believe that bishop g5
shouldn't work
i was thinking that maybe
fabiano will play bishop before
the position is very balanced because i
i'll probably have to play h3 to stop
the mate
and try to bring my bishop i mean my my
position is kind of awkward at the
moment
but the
white center is slow to move can you
actually explain us why bishop g5
is worse than bishop iv and why this f6
move is so important uh yeah the point
of the position is that
black is behind in development
but white's white pawns are a bit far
uh
from influence they're not influencing
anything yet
so
if i play slow after bishop g5
and he gets some time to slowly push his
pawns like h3 i don't know maybe bishop
f3 something like this e4
and then
despite the material advantage
he will get
he will get in the game and uh
structurally you know white has the
center and the bishop on b4 obviously
yeah so while i'm
moving my bishop he will uh conquer the
center and then
e4 g4
rook to g3 then it could be very
dangerous for me
yeah so looks like therefore i i need to
act very quickly
and develop my pieces uh not counting
the pawns at this moment
so f6 looks beautiful also it opens up
the queen to go potentially to h7
yeah it's a tactical idea
and here probably he should have came
back as well maybe bishop f4 here as
well
is the right move actually here it
already doesn't work
but i mean it's not that good anymore
so when was the point of no return in
your opinion
it's hard to tell i thought that this
looks good for me
uh well we were mainly considering
something like this
with fabi i don't know this is
bishop e5 takes
here
he needs to open up the center maybe
this was the way for him to proceed
but uh i'm definitely doing fine i can
take on d4 take on e4 my bishop comes
into the game and uh
yeah this this bishop is not bad anymore
no this was just uh after that it seemed
like and he just lost the trend at some
point and then yeah here i mean it's
kind of surprising quite
well it has a material advantage but
since this center is not moving anywhere
it's a completely lost position
beautiful game beautiful start thank you
for joining us thank you and we'll see
you in the next rounds thanks back to
you
thanks so much lavon for taking the time
to explain this fascinating game
but we have three victories and a very
exciting rest of the day i'm
particularly excited about some of the
round two match-ups as it's the winners
versus losers
yeah that's gonna be a great second
round
i think a lot of people need to come
back into this tournament get their head
back in because those were some tough
losses especially by vladislav artemyev
i thought against fishy anon he just got
wiped off the board and that this is
what i'm talking about wesley so who
lost his first round game is going to be
playing against vichyanan who won his
first game still wesley with memories of
norway not far behind i think he'll
bring some confidence with the white
pieces this is going to be a great
battle and then also we have a wounded
fabi versus a triumphant anishigiri
who's starting with two whites yeah i
think anish feels confident after that
win he got the type of positions he
excels at just a slight pressure wesley
more or less fell apart and i think
anish will be going with a great mindset
into the next round and we're going to
take a quick break and we're going to
leave you with a segment from the
opening ceremonies
welcome to bucharest everybody to the
2019 superbad rapid and blitz health
here at stageary country club it's a
beautiful playing hall a beautiful
setting we have a lot of celebrities
here boris becker is in the house
fabiano caruana and a lot of a lot of
strong chess players let's go and get
the drawing of the lots ready
[Music]
thank you for all your grandchild's
masters and i wish you all
a lot of luck
for sure it can be just one we are but i
suppose all of us will be winner to have
the opportunity on
being here and
to enjoy such a big
tournament first time in romania so good
luck everyone and thank you
[Applause]
as honorable
we had an amazing opening ceremony the
drawing of the lots was made everybody
had a lot of fun the organizer put on a
show for us now we're ready to go back
to the action
[Music]
[Applause]
itself
[Music]
so be surprised be intrigued be
delighted the world chess hall of fame
in st louis is nothing you'd expect and
everything you love
three galleries highlight the history
culture and creativity behind the game
explore chess in ways you never imagined
it's a one-of-a-kind cultural
institution where rare artifacts and
world-class art play together
the world chess hall of fame
mind art experience
founded in 1839 the university of
missouri is steeped in tradition with
more than 30 000 students mizzou is
known for its high academic standards
music program and athletics tradition
this fall another competitive team will
be added to the campus and its
long-standing tradition of excellence
i'm cristian carrillo the head coach of
mizzou's chess team and we will compete
against the nation's top collegiate
programs and represent the tigers all
around the country mizuchas coming fall
2019.
[Music]
so
hey
[Music]
hmm
hello and welcome back to the super vet
rapid and blitz chess in romania
bucharest um our penultimate stop on the
grand chess tour not including of course
the finals and what a bang it started
with some of the players needed to win
this tournament they started off in the
wrong foot fabina carona and sergey
karjakin sergey only got half a point
from what i think was just a completely
winning position fabiano got demolished
by levon aronian but two players that
are hopeful to make it to london just
increase their chances we can see that
vishy annan and levon aronian started
off with the win and ishkiri did as well
although his chances to go to london are
severely diminished compared to the
other players now you know who's sitting
back right now and thinking
all right i need some more bad results
to come in for some folks is one maxim
vashila grav the only player who's
completed all of his events right now he
will not be playing here nor will he be
playing in india he has already put up a
score and he's like i'm there
right now he's the number three player
but it's a precarious third place spot
trying to go to london and he needs some
players to get knocked out we knew that
fabiano had to win this event by winning
he would have surpassed
by winning i should say he will surpass
maxime
so
a loss by fabi maxim says yeah just keep
losing i don't mind that result as you
see there maxima has 36.8 with fabia
25.5 a win here gets him 13 points he
gets to 38.5 and would surpass maxime
with lavon most likely going to qualify
as well passing maxime so maximize
looking at those players who have a
chance of fabiano losing sergey needs to
win to pass maxime as well a draw
maxim's not happy with that but he'll
take it any little point counts that he
knocks him off and wesley so losing as
well he needs wesley to have a poor
result because
wesley has some good chances to make it
but if wesley keeps playing like this
and gets a poor result he might play
himself out of the event because india
is going to be fiery you got to face
back you gotta face magnus you gotta
face ding loren you gotta face nakamura
and nepo those players who might just be
the first four in that event there won't
be a lot of points up for grabs there so
they need to play well here this is
their best chance so maxime after round
one it's only round one feels a little
bit better about his situation
oh and it's a big time here on the set
guys as we are going to go through our
predictions and i think that christian
gorilla is going to also play with us
over in romania but um who wants to
start
alejandro i have to say out of all the
tournaments i've picked a favorite this
one is so tough everybody seems so even
you can pick some of the wild cards it's
not a crazy pick at all i'm a little bit
biased by the way the tournament started
just the way that some of the players
played it's hard not to pick aronian but
you know what i'm gonna go off bit a bit
a bit i don't think i've ever picked him
to win a tournament so i'm going to pick
bishop
all right vichyana great choice maurice
that's such a great choice and after
seeing the first game you think i got to
pick one of those top three players i'm
going to stick with the player that i
thought would be a good chance to win
there were two players i had my eye on
it was wesley so and it was sergey
karjakin i finally settled on sergey
because he's such a phenomenal blitz
player and he has never won one of these
i'm going to say he's due but that first
game not impressed should have been able
to beat a curveball that first game but
i'm going to stick with them anyway and
avoid those other top players although
wow the way they played they had great
chances to win
and um i'm gonna go with lavon after
that round one performance i mean i
cannot blame you levon played amazingly
and when he's on fire he just continues
to be on fire it's very easy for levon
to just start a tournament kind of
poorly and not really make a name for
himself in the event but sometimes he
just catches on fire early and you just
don't stop him and lavon we know that he
won here in st louis he's hungry for
another victory he
needs a couple of points there to
qualify for london he just wants to seal
the deal right here and let's hear what
christian in romania has for us
well guys you picked absolutely
everybody that was interesting but you
left one that i find interesting and
that is of course anish geary
or how we like to call him here dracula
of course anish giri i think he's going
to uh put up a very good performance in
this one
he started off very strong with a
beautiful victory against wesley so by
the way this is a very interesting fact
the highest rated rapid player right now
in this tournament is korobot
nobody picked korobov so i'm not going
to pick korobov i'm going to beat
anishkiri but korobov is definitely in
contention as well he escaped in the
first game against sergey karjakin he's
just starting to play against these guys
starting to feel them and i think he's
going to put up a good performance as
well but i'm going to stick with anish
giri
point christian we saw as we started the
show
that um so was the highest rated rapid
in the tournament but because of his
first round loss he's probably swapped
by the way you guys all picked the three
winners from the first round talk about
biased i know somebody wanted to pick
wesley's soul but after you saw him get
punched in the face you ran away from
him no way in the world you know you
guys
ah i'm surprised the only thing i'm
impressed by is that christian didn't
pick fabi as he always does or i should
say usually does because he did pick
magnus
after a long think a long hard thing
christian we know you wanted to pick
your boy fabi but i i'm impressed you
decided to go off of him right now and
go with a niche just because he saw the
first game look at him he knows that he
saw the first game and there was no way
he was speaking you always accuse me you
always accuse me of picking fabiano but
actually in london last year i picked uh
hikaru nakamura to win his mini match
against fabiano you forgot about that
that's the exception that proves the
rule excuse me you know you picked him
like seven times out of eight so
yes and then during the sink
you decided i chose magnus yes
i did mention that let's get to the game
admirable virtue but let's take a look
at the games and see
um wesley so um versanome this looks
like it's going to be a thriller i think
it's where we have to start because
visciana again repeating the black
pieces
but
he had a great result and this is a
stuff on wesley saw against vichy anand
and we have a reverse benco so for me
this is already what i want to take a
look at a little bit unusual i want to
explain some of the details of this
position after the moves knight f3 d5 c4
d4 has picked up a lot of steam and
specif specifically this position after
b4 a few ways that black can deal with
this expansion on the queen side very
popular has been f6 and e5
putting that pressure on the center
establishing the dominance in the dark
squares
now g5 has picked up some steam as well
in
the latest couple of years it looks like
a blunder of the pawn but it becomes
very complicated after knight takes g5
e5 because the knight kind of runs out
of squares so if the knight retreats i
keep attacking it with e4 the knight has
to go all the way back to g1 and even
the pawn on b4 will be hanging so
that's one way of dealing with the
position but instead bishop plays the
more traditional c5 reverse benco style
the point is that you don't really want
to take on c5 very commonly because
after knight c6 e5 bishop takes c5 black
develops in a very harmonious manner
pretty much gaining advantage of the
position wesley decides i'm going to put
the bishop on b2 just increase the
pressure on this square and we have a
lot of new moves let me just refresh the
position
knight f6 g3 double fianchetto style
this closing of the queen side is very
typical for the structure and the funny
thing is in this kind of positions white
is actually down the tempo compared to
the normal benko because this bishop
would rather be on sorry would rather be
on c1 than on b2 because after i play
the move d3 it's ready to jump to the g5
square so it might seem unusual but
actually white is down a tempo compared
to a normal position
because of this bishop on b2 a position
that we see very commonly with the
colors reversed what this bishop still
being on c1 instead of b2
i like black's position just
as a matter of principle having the
center having more space on uh the
important parts of the board especially
because the queen side cannot be opened
up but it's still just a game and i
think after d3
castle's short
both sides have chances in the position
and let's go on um to the other game
between the victor and the loser from
round one
as of course all the players who lost
are going to be super hungry as anish
giri and fabiano face off a little bit
of a wrinkle here in the move order
let's take a look from the beginning
this game geary started the
game with d4 which fabiano has a big
repertoire against but he decides to
play the move e6 inviting geary to say i
could play e4 and transpose back into
the french defense
you would be wondering what black does
in that case we won't find out because
bob is not traditionally a french player
plays it once in a while but not very
often c4 played instead bishop before
check is kind of the point that you can
play bishop before
immediately bishop d2 a5 you could take
on b4 that leads to completely different
type of scenarios but let's focus on
what happens in the game a3 bishop e7 so
isn't this weird that you put your
bishop on before and then after a3 only
to drop it back to e7 can you shed some
light on that absolutely there's a
couple of details here the bishop on d2
is actually misplaced the bishop is
slightly better placed on c1 because the
queen actually controls the center so
the bishop on d2 is not a developed
piece it doesn't add value to the
position in many cases but more
importantly is the inclusion of the
moves a3 and a5 if black gets on time to
play something like d5
bishop d7 and a4 he's going to clamp
down on the light squares of the queen
side and this is a very common plan in
this structure with the moves of a3 and
a5 it does give up quite a bit of
development time so it's not necessarily
true
that
black's going to get everything that he
wants but that's kind of the ideal and
we will see in the game that after d5
which was played knight f3 knight f6 at
some point black will try to use the
fact that he has this possibility of a4
at some point giri develops the bishop
says that i don't want it on the inside
the pawn chain puts it on f4 so as to
play e3 and not hinder it and we have
this as i believe the current position
uh
traditionally i think blood is not fully
equalizing in this positions but it does
create a little bit more of an imbalance
compared to the normal queen's gambits
that we've seen at the top level it's an
attempt to muddy the waters i think fabi
knows that he cannot just settle for
some kind of draw and he wants to play
more in some sense not go into a
theoretical battle not defend a slightly
worse position just say i have my
chances you have your chances let's go
for it i don't care if it's as
theoretically sound as
you would play in a classical game
and then lavonne versus sergey karjakin
yeah this one
is
uh trying to find rounding out our other
other winner from round one definitely a
berlin i can just tell from the
structure
e4 and of course sergey playing the
berlin almost exclusively with the black
pieces these days
uh d3 we don't see so much of
the end game nowadays
instead of preferring this move d3
bishop c5
bishop takes and we have a very
traditional approach to this structure
let's just go to the current position
and explain what's going on basically
black establishes a very solid structure
both the queen side and the king side
with the moves f6
e5 and a5 b6
everything's protected you have the pair
of bishops as black but white has the
dynamic possibilities and they're
really enhanced with this move king h1
with the idea of f4 and you would be
wondering whether you put the knight so
as to be able to play a four and levon
answer said pretty simply the knight
retreats to g1 so that i can play f4 no
other reason than to do this let's
update what's happening in the position
knight g1 knight f8 so why do you think
he played knight g1 instead of knight e1
uh it just has more possibilities on g1
than on e1 and you want to stuck to
returning to f3 whereas on g1 i could go
to e2 if needed so there's quite a few
reasons why on g1 it's more flexible but
the main one is that on e1 it just has
to return at some point to have three
where so g1 i might have at least an
idea of what to do further
so knight f8 f4 making this break in the
center taking taking knight g6 bishop g3
i like
white a little bit more practically but
black is in a very solid situation here
not a super important moment in a or i
should say match up in a game between
shakira mamadirov and artemia chakra are
simply eliminated from any chance of
going to london and artemis is a wild
card so just the game these two are
playing
basically for pride artemia saying i
just lost a bad game maybe i can play
against someone who hasn't been doing so
well in any of these events but just a
curiosity take a look at this moment
after the move e6 this move
weakening the dark squares a little bit
but preparing d5 very solid
b4 played by shakriar three pawns
abreast well if three is good then why
not make it four after the move a4 queen
e7 a4
just pushing his pawns down the board
not developing anything behind it of
course queen takes on b4 runs into
bishop a3 to be sure he's not going to
fall for this one but a4
instead he played to break up the
structure which is something we would
expect to play the move a5 testing why
is he putting this movement now i
remember playing something like this a
long time ago against a good friend of
mine now closer colas back in the days
in brooklyn and the move b5
he also got into pawn to c5 into c6 and
my knight never came out ever in the
position now this is the kind of thing
you have to be careful of a move like d5
for example of course you're going to
run into bishop to a3 yet again so
there's no pushing there so expect to
see the move b5 land on the board talk
about advancing pawns
this is anand's second game in a row
with black
and look at his pawn formation as well
black having extended down the board
against wesley so he's playing black
looks like he's got a lot of space white
is looking for someday when he can play
the f4 move and then to get that going
so anan with black for the second time
an important moment for him if he can do
well now
who knows it might just set the wind to
his sails
and i believe we have christian in
bucharest right now also with a common
as well
i think it's important to go to uh the
battle of the wild cards as well the
game between korobov and laquan liam
korobov the number one uh in player in
this tournament in terms of rapid blitz
ratings he is playing against le juan
liam who is no slouch he is a former
blitz world champion so this is a big
battle and i think this was an important
key moment uh in this position white has
to focus in the center has to go rook
cafe one potentially rook 81 afterwards
and break with the move e4 instead he
chose a strategically dubious
attempt via b4 the problem is the bishop
d6 and the queen on e7 right now create
this beautiful battery on the a3 f8
diagonal and le quang liam understood
that bishop d7 protecting the pawn on c6
preparing this move this very important
move b5 to solidify the structure on the
queen side i'm going to break with a5
and then your pawns on a3 and b4 are
going to become huge weaknesses and that
is exactly what's happening right now
bishop to a5 immediately attacking the
pawn on b4 queen to b2 i think we have
another move on the board rook case a
takes before a takes before now the pawn
on b4 is going to be a weakness forever
and i think black has amazing chances to
score a huge victory in this one and
white simply doesn't have any
counterplay
and um interesting game it will be
indeed but meanwhile key moment from the
game between lavonne and sergey cardiac
and two of the tournament favorites
where something big was missed i think
this is sergey second time in a row he
just believes his opponent and doesn't
even check to see if there's a killing
blow
this move of levon aronian is a howler
he played the move queen d2
extremely careless and
let's just put it bluntly kayaking
didn't even think about it because had
he thought for two seconds think at home
guys those of you in the audience
without an engine what do you do here
for black i mean is
look at the loose pieces in the position
if you take on c4 in this position white
has to take with the b pawn because the
queen is hanging and then you realize
that queen is hanging and then you just
say who's defending this pawn on e4 i'll
just take rook takes c4 and guys this is
a very basic tactic it's not like i need
an engine to see this one
rookie four is just a free pawn an
important one because the central
dominant pawn that white hat in this
position and sergey just missed it he
just played the move bishop b4 saying
please move your queen out of this way
away from the tactic put the queen on c1
and now we just have a game complicated
as it is a huge miss by sergei karaki in
my opinion who just keeps falling for
this it feels like every time somebody
blunders against sergey it's crazy
sergey just believes them we saw wesley
blunder against him or was it in zagreb
easy easy win and this position where he
just could have stolen a pawn right away
completely insane and he did play f5
instead and now pawn takes f5 bishop f5
yeah he still has a good position yeah i
was going to say i i do like black with
that he has the pair of bishops he has
solved this problem of the center space
f5 is a very desirable move so in many
senses his position is still great it's
just the fact that he keeps missing we
started the last game i mean the last
game the same thing happened can you
imagine if the ads were here missing
that free call
oh my god yasser he must be watching
somewhere and just
being so upset free pawn plus the pair
of bishops who would have given sergey a
winning position no doubt and quite a
big mistake by him we have scintillating
games i have to agree completely with
christian though this position between
antoine corbeau and necron limb is just
going horribly for the ukrainian player
the tactics of the position will not
lend himself to the position because
black is so active you've already
doubled on the a file you already have
this pressure this pressure is already
in existence and white hasn't justified
why
he has given up the pair of bishops you
have the bishops on d6 the bishop on d7
very well placed and this battery was
dismantled so i don't have to really
worry about the f7 pawn really this
looks
all black to me in this position
meanwhile wesley sews game against
vishyana and um shaping up to be a very
fascinating closed battle
as wesley preps for f4
something went wrong here for vichy i'm
sorry but you're not supposed to allow
e4 ever
you're getting killed right well
in this this kind of positions
eventually white kind of tries to play
e4 but the problem is that it kills your
bishop on g2
so when you play as black b6 and all
these kind of moves you have to be
careful of bishop c6 the reason is that
you trade the bishops and then you play
e4 and e4 doesn't kill your bishop
anymore so you kind of get the structure
that you want and this is kind of what
i'm talking about you're not really
supposed to allow this i'm not really
sure what if you played rookie seven
instead of uh bishop d7 yeah but okay
the bishop on c6 is not easily targeted
i can still just play e4 and the problem
is that the bishop is now outside of the
pawn chain and okay the computer doesn't
like what i'm doing but i really don't
care because the point is that i play e4
and i play f4 the next move from black
okay maybe you can stop it for a while
with 96 or knight g6 but it's not so
easy to play black anymore when the
bishop is outside of the pawn chain when
the bishop's on g2 usually you have to
worry as white consistently of this
problem but now that he's managed to
both trade the bishops and get e4 in he
has a lot of maneuvering time to put the
knight on g2 like maybe the bishop on c1
bring the rook over and then play f4
whereas for black it's not so easy to
actually create a strategical threat
because f5 is very difficult to achieve
and i just kind of run out of ideas you
do have a decent position but what is
black's idea here i see that black is
actually being given as preference by
the computer but i personally prefer
white already from this position because
you have a concrete plan and black
doesn't and we do have a few more moves
in the position the engine right here
before you make the next one the engine
here prefer the move g6
uh in making that point you were talking
about the move f4 trying to slow up the
possibility of versus a tactic on the
diagonal with the queen able to hit the
knight on h4 so you have to be careful
about putting f4 forward because of that
tactic but in the meantime black can
also fight for
this square f4 continuously with a
knight on e6 and then a queen on c7 even
and maybe move the knight on f6 out of
the way and somehow someday get his own
f5 break-in it is a little bit slow that
that is the time he's counting on to see
if he can pull that off but the way he
put his knight on g6
wesley said thanks very much now that
your knights on g6 i don't see you
trying for f5 anytime soon and he just
retreats and then he just dropped his
knight back and said it's all about f4
now and even in this position i'm
wondering why he didn't go to f5 which
looks even more tempting to me but okay
knight g2 with the idea of f4
it
it just feels like it's easier to play
for the wide side did he really play
rook cafe i guess another strange one
just asking for f4 i guess he really
wants to play 98 on f5 himself but the
problem is that with this configuration
of bishops the moment that you play f5 i
will be very happy to take and establish
this knight on e4 and that's going to be
a thorn for black the rest of the game
but what do you do about f4 and f4 is on
the board now f4
looks like you'll never get any getting
in
any kind of f5 yourself and f5 itself is
threatened well this is what i was
talking about when the bishop's still on
the board like the bishop on g2
and my bishop on c8 is still alive i
have the move knight g4
imagine this bishop still light on g4 i
play knight g4 and i start threatening
the knight coming to e3 you will need to
play knight g2 which you can't because
normally there is a white bishop on that
square and this is what i'm talking
about the trait of that bishops is so
beneficial for white because he's down
on space and these breakthroughs that he
makes are only possible now because he
has a good configuration of pieces that
wouldn't have been possible with the
bishops on the board
and i'm not saying that black is
completely worse here i think it's a
playable position but things are going
in west this way i see that he has taken
an f4 played him with 98 i like this
setup for black compared to some of the
others at least he will try to get f5 in
i don't like the fact that wesley's
bishop's on v2 i still would have rather
have it on c1 but
i'm starting to like white's position
it's just that he got the central
dominance that he wanted
so you're saying black is going to be
playing f5 here
i think at some point he should play f5
try to coax white into playing the move
e5 so that i can retrieve the bishop
somewhere and establish this knight on
e6 a very slow maneuvering game
traditionally the kind of moves the kind
of games that computers don't really
understand very well
at least a traditional stockfish type of
engines
and
i
i just like white i think white is doing
really well on the other hand black has
their own resources play f5 establish a
knight on e6 difficult to make progress
for both sides well this one will be
really fun to watch and of course so
crucial to our standings as
wesley so needing to have a good
tournament
to keep his chances
um alive to make it into london and i'm
not in in a similar situation although
he had a great start already well let's
jump to some of the other games back to
this aronian karjakin game keeping me
fascinated of course correcting
blundering basically what i consider to
be a win away by not seeing that free
pawn in the center but he's still doing
a pretty well for himself the pair of
bishops causes a strong impression
especially this one on c3 because well
you can't fight for the open file with
rookie one it also kind of hinders the
queen i would like to move this rook
back into the position somehow this
bishop on c3 is not allowing me to do so
and yes white has some good pieces the
bishop g3 particularly is hitting the
pawn on c7 that seems to be quite
annoying and there is no clear weakness
that black can attack immediately but
the activity of the pieces just makes me
prefer black's positioning things sergey
has gotten the batter of levon aronian
uh because the knights they're okay but
they don't have anywhere to go and we
know that when we think about the battle
between knights and bishops you want to
have those knights anchored to a good
square and the problem is that this
knight will run out of anchors at some
point you always have to be worried
about what happens if b5 because the
knight will have to move and then i have
to tactically make sure the knight can
go somewhere useful i don't have control
over e5
which i would love to do as white i
would love to play d4 and control the
pawn the square on e5 but i just cannot
do it the bishop on c3 is now a sword in
white's position i just don't know how
to get rid of it right and you have to
worry about something like you know
knight
kick the knight away then play knight f4
and rookie two
things like that are in the position
that said
a big time advantage for lavon as sergey
is deep in thought and at 13 minutes
with 20 minutes for lavon so that could
become a big factor as well what's
lavon's body language in the interview
with uh with christian little strange
i felt like he wasn't excited that he
won the game and he even looked like he
was a little perturbed for some reason
it was quite odd to me uh to see that
from him now you see him popping out
popping out that chest trying to get
some energy for the individual game but
there's somebody rooks here i'm sorry he
just played rooks is that what happened
yes he did play rook on a c a to c8 that
is the least active move i've seen in my
life
easy i mean that's active
it would have been worse but what is the
point of this move he's defending c7 and
this is the only idea that this could
possibly have because he's going to
unleash his queen and then worry about
some exchanges what a bizarre
definitely a bizarre looking move and
then i i saw there's another bizarre
move i want to point out that happened
here with the fabiano caruana game and
anish geary and he's played this move
bishop to e5 saying you know what i
don't want you to take my bishop on
uh g3 and he could have played the move
f6 slight weakening of the position to
be sure i mean his knight does become a
little suspect but if his bishop drops
back then of course he can take it
whenever he wants to and then after this
move fabi played rook to a5 now here the
move
h3 preserves the bishop permanently now
you'll never do anything with this
bishop for sure a great opportunity for
him to play it there instead of playing
that he played the move rook d1 and left
the option yet again for f6 so must be
that they're evaluating f6 as not that
great a move for black because of that
slight weakening but it seems like an
opportunity to me
definitely a rich game one that fabi is
desperate
to win desperate he cannot lose if he
starts that downhill slide that's it
this will be his last two raw it is his
last at the moment anyway his last
chance to possibly qualify in an event
he must win but as i was talking about
body language this looks like somebody
stole his favorite pet
this is not the kind of look and then
when he saw the camera come up he tried
to smile his way into it but even in the
interview he did not look like lavonne
was here panchik they stole pawnchick
that's the way of his dog yeah i i i he
really love they love his dog i mean
he'd be out in the search party right
now yeah exactly he wouldn't even be a
strawberry i think if they stole ariana
nobody would care but if they saw
pawnchick i mean
would be all over that immediately he
would just abandon the tournament i
don't really understand what fabia's
doing i have to agree with maurice that
if you play knight h5 to capture the
bishop you kind of have to play f6 to
actually uh back this bishop on the
position because the way that he's
playing right now it just looks like his
position is very awkward you even have
to worry that if you ever take on e5
that i'll take back with the pawn and
i'm not entirely sure that you can save
this knight on h5 just to give a sample
variation if you take here and i take
here i am turning g4 and this knight is
trapped but if you play g6 you have the
problem that this queen might just
checkmate me with queen h6 not to
mention that there might be some
discovery with the bishop on uh d3 but i
think queen h6 is just extremely strong
i don't know if i started playing for f6
at some point just to
get your pieces to defend maybe i just
kick out your knight first g4 and then
queen h6 and i'm threatening knight g5 i
don't see how you defend this at all
that's just that game so that means that
you're not even going to take on e5
after you made the move bishop d6 and
when you start realizing that you cannot
play bishop take c5 you're kind of
wondering what are you doing with your
position because this knight is just
stranded on h5 with the bishop having
played already to d6 you don't really
have knight f6 i'll just take an e5 and
you're probably just getting mated in
this position right i mean this bishop's
open this is coming to h6 so
strange bobby's position just lacks
harmony because he didn't logically
follow up the move knight h5 and very
often this happens in chess that if you
make a committal decision and you don't
follow it up with logic
then your position starts to lose sense
and that that's what i think is going on
with fabian's position it doesn't have
any sense to it why is the knight on h5
why is the bishop on these things they
are not harmonious and that makes his
position just worse he doesn't have any
good way of continuing and look at
white's position a picture of harmony
now i mean you didn't get a chance to
snap off the bishop and we look at y's
position we say yeah everything looks
like a normal chess position and we have
a sense of normalcy patterns that we
recognize in chess easy harmonious play
the pieces are well connected to one
another very tight you see a nice gear
he plays that kind of chess very tightly
bunched together his pieces centralized
he likes this kind of play and by the
way this is his second
white in a row anish while anand is
playing his second black in a row
somebody has to suffer it at some point
in the tournament but anish getting that
second white boy if he could take fabi
down and go 2-0 the dream of maybe
qualifying well that's far off for now
but he looks he looks pretty rested he
looks pretty confident leaning back in
the chair right now speaking of rusty
let's remember he is one of the few
people in this tournament that didn't
play the grand swiss so he did have some
more time to prepare he just comes out
from a decent performance at the
european team championship i wouldn't
say it was stellar but it was all right
he had some good games i thought his
attacking game was absolutely brilliant
if you haven't checked it out check out
the first win of anish giri in the
european team championship absolutely
wonderful devastation of his opponent
but
he's starting off in the right foot here
and he has an excellent position against
fabiana carrano let's have some updates
in of course this wesley game that we've
been talking about against vichy anand
i see a couple of knights have been
traded and this queen has landed on the
h4 square but it does still feel that
it's white that has a slight edge in
this position uh okay but queen h4 you
know it's stopping me from playing rook
h3 because the f4 pawn is tender yes and
also more importantly i cannot quickly
remaneuver because i would like to play
queen g2 and rook af1 just bring
everybody back into the party play the
bishop to c1 put the rook on h3 knight
on f3 but it's because of this pressure
on uh the f4 square that i can't really
do this now you might be wondering why
doesn't uh wesley just push this pawn
just go e5 get rid of this bishop so i
can maneuver my pieces put the knight on
e4 yes it is very likely this is a good
move but you have to make it with a
little bit of care because this
releases the control that i have on the
f5 square and if i get my knight as
black to f5 i would consider that to be
sufficient counter chances if at some
point i put mine out on f5 i have the f6
break i could do something while you
remove all of your pieces well he did
play the move king h1 a waste of time in
the position and now bishop and now
knight to g7 saying now if you play e5
all right yeah i got the memo i have the
five square to plan that night on so
this is looking like
a little bit of hesitation on wesley's
part maybe that pair of knights traded
that night we didn't like on g6 traded
off the board making anna have a little
bit more freedom and you know rapid
chess is not solely about accurate moves
we saw anand play some gorgeous gay a
gorgeous game and and maybe all his
moves were great moves but it's not just
about accurate moves it's about feel
flow intuition magnus said that himself
when he's got flow it's all going well
together you just keep playing the next
move the next move and you feel good
about whatever you're doing whatever the
position you'll figure it out and anand
is showing that especially on the clock
he's got a lead on wesley who
is simply one of the best rapid players
in the world but he's the one who's down
on time right now and looking uncertain
about how to continue
yeah i mean i still rather be white now
that we've said all this because
it just seems like an easier flow of
play and going back to what you said
about magnus i mean it just feels like
the moves come easier to wipe but on the
other hand it's white that's somehow
spending more time than black you can
see that wesley doesn't perhaps feel
comfortable in the structure perhaps he
doesn't have a lot of experience with
this kind of positions he's not
particularly known to be a king's indian
player for example which is a king's
indian-esque position
but
a lot for grabs i think in this game
definitely and by the way if black plays
a move like f6 yeah slows down that e5
break and then starts punishing that f
pawn with knight h5 knight h5 coming in
and there's some tactics around the king
because there's a queen h2 mate
you're gonna have to start watching
what's going on on the board now there
is rook h3 but this queen takes f4 so
what's the deal here if black gets a
couple of moves in while white is
figuring out what to do and there he
goes he said okay that's it i gotta do
it right now e5 it doesn't matter i'm
conceding the f5 square i've just got to
get a bit of a clamp and get the knight
to e4 yeah but the thing is
if i was going to play e5 and then you
compare what is more useful the king on
h1 for white or the knight to g7 for
black and it's obvious
that's what we're saying
just the way he blinked there's a waste
of time he should have gone ahead with
his plan uh now bishop back to e7 and
unlocking just and here's the we're just
gonna play with the
knight already on g7 i could even
consider retreating the bishop somewhere
else and the reason that maybe i want to
put the bishop on b8 is that once knight
e4 comes and i play knight h5 assuming
i'm not blundering anything tactically i
could really revamp this position with
f6 and allow this bishop to eventually
really target all of the structure here
now bishop 7 is obviously more solid and
follow the safer choice because there is
that rick h3 idea and network takes h5
might be might be a problem yes just to
illustrate what uh the problem is that
maybe
this might have some issues that rook h3
and even if you take on f4 i could still
take on h5 and knight f6 check will at
the end fork the rook and the king so
this might be unplayable maybe the move
bishop e7 is quite necessary but the
fact that black's even considering these
things only stems from the fact that
king h1 was a complete loss of a tempo
could you tell me about loss of a tempo
this move rook c8
just i need to understand knight b2
going to where is it a threat to the
bishop looks perfect why bishop d4
buying a rookie seven and double or
something else the knight goes back to
c4 what's the point of this dance rookie
seven queen d2 now the queen gets into
the game and now he challenges the rook
on the e line what was up with that last
sequence do you have an explanation
alejandro because i i don't get it why
did this sequence happen might be too
what was that
so i understand ib2 with the desire of
getting rid of the bishop on c3
now why you voluntarily move the bishop
before
white actually goes knight d1 which is a
it's such a sad move to play right you
want to encourage this move to be played
before you retreat the bishop
yeah that i'm not really sure about
because okay after knight c4 i control
the e3 square you could just say i'm
repeating moves no problem right but you
should put the bishop back on c3 but
this is an awkward time to play them
with rookie 7 because well after queen
d2 as you mentioned i've taken control
over such a crucial square and i was
mentioning earlier when this bishop was
on c3 it hindered the rook on b1 because
the rook couldn't swing back into the
game and i was controlling the file but
clearly i mean things have changed now
that the queen is on d2 this is stunning
and now double rooks challenger rooks
and yes you do still have that dark
square
actually it's the light square bishop
the two bishops but it's the light
square bishop that's the bishop superior
theoretically to the knight but this
bishop is not doing anything a white
structure just simply mitigates against
any kind of incursions by black's bishop
and it doesn't look like there's
anything right it's hitting a grounded
what just happened this was very strange
sergey just let go entirely of his
advantage meanwhile let's take a look at
the game between anish yuri
and fabiano because anish is trying to
capitalize on this position this pawn on
e5
the weak knight on h5 the weak pawn on
b6 he's just played e5
um and
now
this looks hopeless
i mean the problem play queen c3 there's
bishop h7 check right this this doesn't
work because i just hang the queen
uh i'm not so sure that g4 is a threat
because of maybe actually g4 is a threat
because queen c6 is bishop b4 yeah let
me just illustrate that if i play
something random with black i don't know
let me i don't even know how to defend
this pawn even if i didn't have this
problem with the knight i'm not actually
sure how you defend the spawn on b6 and
that kind of segues into what i wanted
to say g4 is a threat no doubt g4 will
win a knight but even if i defend from
that by playing i don't know f5 uh i'm
kind of giving up b6 for free
you might have to play you might
actually have to play a five but it's a
very sad move to play how do i defend
this knight on h5
i'm not actually sure how you do this i
mean f5 there's a really sound there's a
rook a five move it's rookie five rookie
five must be an engine suggestion
because i would have never thought of
this all right it is an engine
suggestion i mean it runs into knight c4
cycle and he fights he found it and he
found out
and now not why so knight c4 there's
what queen c6 now is that the idea that
becomes a possibility maybe maybe you
just put the rook on c5 honestly maybe
yeah and he's getting and he's getting
some things because of the queen c6 yeah
queen c6 threats but i can just take on
pc the important point here is that g4
no longer works obviously because the
knight has the f6 square after the tempo
right right rookie five key moves yeah
but if i'm calculating correctly rook
takes b6 defends the pawn on e5 because
if i take on e5 i believe i can take on
b7
and then d3
as well yeah but is
yeah this actually this is enough
counterplay the rook on d3 is attacking
the knight on d2 and i should have
something and our knight now has the
nice f force material equality yeah
material sequel no this is uh perhaps
you don't want to give him this this you
have to punish him hard for
this for sure maybe i mean i can
can i throw in bishop takes h7 note that
doesn't work well nice move by fabi
getting back into this game with rookie
five yeah it's actually a surprising
thing it's very nice from fabiano i've
completely missed the move rook a5
fighting fabi and let's go to christian
in romania
well i just want to jump on the analysis
uh that you guys were making because
after rook a5 rook takes b6 actually
works after rook takes e5 rook takes b7
rook takes e3 we have the inter mezzo
bishop takes h7 after king takes h7 i
take on c7 and this is just a pawn up
your knight is still out of play on h5
but this is not the main point i wanted
to make the main point i wanted to make
is in this moment what is this move rook
to a7
it's inconceivable that a guy like
fabiano could play a move rook to a7
unless he's completely out of shape it
just looks bad and of course after e5
the knight is going to be trapped if i
was not even the strongest objectively
move but e5 looks so dominant and of
course rook a5 he found this and we're
going to see whether anish is going to
choose i'm sure he sees rook takes b6
calculates the move bishop takes h7
along the way and he sees that he can be
a pawn up so he has a decision to make
he can
defend the pawn on e5 with knight c4 or
he can go into this endgame upon up and
that's just going to be uh risk free i
think that's an amazing choice that
anish has at this point in in the game
let's go back to maurice
great point christian and that winning
of a pawn and risk-free play right up
anisha's alley that's the way he likes
to do it forget about unclear keep it
murky no i see a clear pawn in my pocket
and there's no real risk it's an end
game maybe the guy can try to defend but
um
we'll take it you saw how he did to
wesley in the last game now this one
anand putting on a clinic first of all
it looked like we
we were just extolling the virtues of
white's position but anan is
systematically outplaying wesley take a
look at the technique he's used the move
e5 went on the board bishop to e7 and
after knight
the move f5 was played this move f5
hitting the knight saying if you take
then your pawn on f4 is going to be weak
forever and we will put everything to
attack it meantime meanwhile just take a
look at this as the game breaks open you
don't want to have your bishop and your
rook in a corner while all of black's
pieces are coordinated and ready to
pounce so taking is just simply
unacceptable as a line i mean you could
play it but then this pawn is just going
to become weak forever instead after f5
he played rook h3 gaining a tempo queen
to g4 now he could repeat rook g3 and
challenge this queen instead he played
knight to g3 and gave anan and i believe
anan has moved anan actually went on the
board i didn't expect this one h5
looking to play h4 is this is this real
h5 knight to e2 and h4
this
okay this looks different i didn't
expect this direction at all from ana
and this knight is a little funny
because now it looks like the queen and
the rooks well i guess the queen can't
leave yet because of this pin
because of the threat but he played
bishop to c1 at first preparing to get
this rook in the game at some point this
maneuver with h5 will seem very
ambitious maybe it was necessary the
game has gone super sharp now a lot of
concrete points will come out of this
position as anand has placed his knight
on e6 as we see there on the board
but that queen and that pawn on g6 wow
this
this looks
alejandro chime in i i'm uh i'm not
really thrilled by the development for
anan but it looks like he's playing with
a lot of confidence well you were
mentioning that you thought wesley was
getting outplayed by anan with this move
f5 but actually i didn't like the move
f5 at all when i looked at this position
anand has placed his pieces in a way
that he was trying not to play f5 and
it's not such a big concession for white
to just move the knight out of the
center i actually didn't think that the
move f5 was very good in this position
from a human point of view i don't know
what the engine says but i thought you
wanted to keep the move f6 as a resource
and then the knight wanted to go to f5
not the pawn so i was very i was kind of
shocked by this move f5 and after rook
h3 here knight g3 yeah perhaps the
computer still prefers black but
honestly i'm a little bit worried about
my queen
on g4 perhaps because of the positions
of the pieces i really shouldn't because
it's difficult to construct a way to
trap it and they bang down a lot more
moves and we'll take a look because
right now let's update the position
after 96 rook f3
it just feels like white has infinite
time now
without the threat of f6 white has
infinite time to improve the position
because black will never do anything and
that worries me that infinite time
because that pawn on h4 could become
stranded if we get a bishop on f2 for
instance yeah and it's not so crazy i
mean queen f2 the rook is going to swing
to g1 and i'll put the rook back on h3
the bishop will come to e1 then i'll
play queen g2 there's a lot of moves i'm
banging out but what is
what exactly is i'm not going to do in
the meanwhile he seems to be kind of
preparing the movie g5 that is exactly
what he's preparing which is a human
approach but
that will leave a lot of weaknesses
behind and i'm not entirely sure that
he's prepared or he's ever going to be
prepared enough to actually play g5
because it creates so many weaknesses in
his own camp specifically the f5 pawn
has to be protected somehow before i can
play g5 and i just don't see a good way
to do so
and how critical is this game to both of
these players you know it's wesley and
anand who are both fighting
for one of those two final spots in
london as we believe that dean loren and
magnus carlson have it all but locked up
certainly magnus does dig loren as well
but those two spots otherwise very much
in doubt levon looks pretty good to get
one of them the fourth one wide open
yeah and this might be a position in
which nothing actually happens more or
less what happened in this game where
korobov he was under pressure but at
some point he was able to escape into an
opposite color end game and bishop end
game and when that happened i mean that
was pretty much a dead game after that
uh let's take a look at some of the
other games we spent a little bit of
time here in wesley so versus vishy
i wanted to go back to this position of
iranian to see if it picked up uh
picked up is not the way to describe it
yeah this looks that one
that one is
you know this can be a little bit
unpleasant for black
because without any real time to think
if i get a bishop to e5 i just trade the
rooks and then i play my queen to f4 and
i play the move h3 this structure
doesn't hold up as well
as normal positions that's why we played
rook c8 earlier yeah perhaps right sure
yeah but this all the pawns being on the
dark squares is worse than white's pawns
being on the light squares because this
bishop coming to d1 is less realistic of
on target angle for the pawns than it is
to just have the bishop on e5 and target
the entire board so i wouldn't chalk
this as dead i i do think that sergey's
position is a bit unpleasant here can we
play for c6 and b5 no i'm sure that with
precise play this is a draw zero percent
chance that this is winning for white
but
it's unpleasant and with your clock
ticking down already knowing that you've
made some inaccurate moves to get to
this position
yeah you're black's okay
by the way i mean while we're looking at
this one and ruminating on the
possibility of the draw of the win
anan continues to play with
assertiveness in his game he just seems
so confident and on the clock as well as
he's more than double the time of his
opponent and you were talking about him
not being able to play g5 he said i'm
playing g5 that's that's happening and
it has happened takes played and now
bishop takes on the board now this is
dropping a pawn to be sure rook takes on
f5 rook takes queen takes is possible
now the move queen takes e2 of course
runs into queen takes e6 with check
but he has an amazing move i don't know
if he sees it from afar this amazing
retreat and it has we're gonna see this
position at least queen takes on the
board and as soon as i said it he played
it queen to e8
when you're seeing moves like that
you're on tremendous form you play the
move g5 so you can drop your queen back
to e8 not to defend this nine on e6 i
should say not solely but the main point
being able to play the move queen a8
with check to that king forcing trades
on the board this e5 pawn may be extra
but it won't last long and even if it
does it's hard to make any kind of
progress this move is absolutely
spectacular the idea of playing g5
dropping a pawn to retreat your queen to
swing to the other side of the board
that's baller chess i love it that's
baller chester i love it this one's a
great maneuver i don't care if it works
or it doesn't work
absolutely yeah you're seeing the board
clear and fresh you're seeing the whole
board you're queen sitting on h5 and
you're thinking about the a8 square
that's ballers there's nothing more
unpleasant than seeing them with queen
eight and then you're thinking he
defended the night and then you realize
yeah wait a second if i move my queen
somewhere awful i'm just getting mated
that's incredible that that is
absolutely great i think we have more
insights from bucharest with christian
carrillo
breaking news guys as in the game
between girianish and uh caruana giri
didn't actually go for the simple rook
takes b6 as we were mentioning he
actually spent a lot of his time now
he's down to his last three minutes and
he played the move rook to e1 now of
course you're defending the pawn on e5
and you're trying to play g4 next move
and just simply capture that knight the
problem is you just spend almost all
your time you have three minutes left
the position gets wild i can play rook
to c5 attack the pawn on c3 if you go g4
then i'm simply going to go rook to d8
you see your pieces are a little bit
clustered and defenseless potentially
after gtx h5 rooked ac3 black is just
simply winning so in this position after
rook to e1 black has options he has more
time i think fabiano is back in the game
and let's update that game we do have a
couple more moves rook d8 very standard
move here by fabiano caron he gets that
rook into the game but more importantly
he tactically defends against the threat
that was generated of g4 after rook d8
you don't have the move g4 because of
the pressure down on this file i can
play many things but i suspect that the
easiest is to just put the knight on f4
take advantage of the fact that the
bishop on d3 is hanging after queen
takes f4 you can simply take this and of
course now it's black on a dominant
position with this excellent bishop on
b7 that's the reason that geary
retreats the bishop to f1 renewing this
threat of g4 i still find some problems
with this knight coming back into the
game i have to solve this tactically i'm
a little bit tempted by the move rook c5
because if i can see this properly after
g4 rook takes c3 should win the queen is
not so flexible where he can defend the
knight on d2 and the king's side and the
position on f4 i think something's got
to give and you probably have to play
rook c5 and he has played a russian c4
just defending the pawn and now comes a
bit of an important detail how do i get
this knight back into the game because
g4 is still hanging in many places but
white has tied himself down to this idea
because now the bishop on f1 is passive
the rook only one and the queen on e3
are stuck defending the pawn on e5 so if
this doesn't tactically work he's
basically destroyed his own advantage he
needs to make g4 work somehow and if
fabi can defend against it he's back in
the game this is a key question of how
to do it right now so g4 now um c4
played by the way on the board yeah so
um so you're saying that g4 queen c so
suppose we just put a move on the board
like b5 right yeah b5 might be the move
and then if g4
yeah g4 i'm not so sure about right now
but okay g4 the point is that queen c6
yeah i don't have a good way of
defending against the checkmate on h1
when i had my bishop on d3 i had bishop
e4
but now with the bishop on f1 i don't
have bishop g2 clearly and if you play
f3 i think i should just be able to take
my g3 i will eventually lose this knight
but i will create so much counter play
on the other side of the board that i
really don't care about it yeah this
doesn't look promising not at all i
think gary's letting go of his advantage
and h5 is also possible if we really
wanted to keep that knight you know
playing either h4 or um coercing a
capture g6 play though that's g6 okay
just to try to maintain the night with
knight g7 maurice your thoughts on the
other big game this is just an
incredible game and even incredible
mistakes take a look at this move anon
played the move bishop back to e7 this
was a flawed move because of a move that
wesley didn't have time to calculate and
said
i don't know if that works let me just
go for something more natural this move
bishop b7 is beginning the threat rook
g5 so he could take this pawn but you
have knight f4 here but the moment you
see 904 on the board you said wait are
we work f7 what are you doing this is a
problem well bishop to d2 seems way too
defensive you got to play this move this
is just computer chess to hold on the
pawn you need time to realize first of
all bishop g5 is not playable because
suddenly knight takes on e6 and breaks
the pin and hits this bishop on g5 and
that would get the job done the main
question though is after this after
you've sorry allowed this position what
if he just plays rook f5 he's going to
take your pawn like what are you doing
well it turns out king g2
super precise guarding this pawn
guarding the rook and after takes knight
g6 and then this move rookie two is met
by rook back and suddenly it is
black for sorry white for choice in this
position as this h h-pawn is under
attack this bishop and all these pawns
are a major problem he had to find all
these moves instead he retreated with
the move rook f2 right here he didn't
see all that he played rook f2 rook g5
by anan and now he was back in business
and after just a couple of moves he was
able to actually bring his king into the
game and
corral this pawn and that caused a draw
in the game and it is unon again at one
and a half wesley so at only a half a
point i know like i said he might be
making some kind of small mistakes guys
but these are the kind of mistakes you
can forgive it's not the ones that it's
just howlers he's playing moves you have
to find deeper moves in order to beat
him i'm not looking good right now in
the tournament that's right and
meanwhile our money game is definitely
going to be anish giri and fabiano as
that game has been drawn as this is the
only one with a queen still on the board
and super tense well they're under four
minutes on the board in the lavon
that is an end game though uh this game
not really happy with the way this
knight is jumping around but at least
it's not dead so that's a plus for fawzi
fans that's the first game i mean three
minutes to four minutes now of course we
do have the delay but yeah we're kb1
um you had a couple more moves right
right
take on the board uh after the move rook
d8 bishop f1 rook c5 c4 we had g6 just
to save the night right rook b1
voluntarily put the knight on g7 saying
i want to go to a five gear had nothing
to do with that the knight does retreat
all the way back to e8 not really sure
where the knight is going much sadder
square huh it is a pretty sad square on
the other hand this rook is pretty well
placed the rook on the 8 is fine the
bishop's on the long diagonal i feel
that black is doing okay unfortunately i
have this bar that's telling me that
white is better but i just don't
understand why white is better this
looks fine the 98 is pretty bad as a
piece but it feels like black has
improved and everything else is is on
top queen c6 is kind of on top you mean
you could try to trade the bishops with
bishop g2 but i don't see why it would
be so scary such an end game couple
moves just played 94 was apparently much
better or even f4 but bishop g2 no dice
as this is allowed this trade on g2 and
now the c4 pawn
you can't move your knight off of the d2
square so there's pressure for black
everywhere very effective rook on the c5
square doing work on two weak pawns in
the position his only problem right now
is where does the e8 knight belong i
think our knight
will probably not move because if i ever
move this knight after word about knight
e4 knight f6
so i think the night it's a bit of a sad
night but it does an important defensive
resource my instinct would be to leave
it there and just improve the rest of
the position by the way did you see how
quickly on each move that made that last
move he's feeling the blitz mode that he
has to be in right now with the clock
ticking down he's double not quite
double the time down but he's feeling
that pressure right now of the clock and
both sides will start to pick up we're
going to see some imperfect moves appear
on the board and it's going to be who
can hold their nurse
nice move work before though
attack and defense and we've got a
christian with news from romania
i still want to stick with this game
because i think this was a very
instructive moment in the game he played
the move bishop g2 this looks very
natural because you want to exchange the
bishops and then jump with the knight to
e4 and potentially go to f6 try to
corral the king and checkmate the king
but the better move much better move
would have been knight to e4 we're going
to exchange this
pair of pieces the bishop b7 and the
knight on d2 because right now the
bishop on c1 plays two very important
roles first of all i'm going to defend
the pawn on c4 and second of all and
much more important i'm going to have
the bishop next to my king and you're
not going to be able to create any sort
of threats against the king on g1 my
position is very safe i have control
over the light squares and now i'm just
start going to start to attack your uh
pawn structure i'm going to go rook to
b4 attack the pawn on a4 attack the pawn
on b6 and this position is extremely
extremely difficult he got tempted by
the fact that after the exchange of the
bishops with bishop g2 the knight could
potentially go to e4 d6 f6 but the
knight will stay on e8 the black knight
will stay on e8 and i'm just going to
have a very safe position i'm going to
put the queen on c6 as black put the
rook on c8 and potentially the opponent
c4 is going to become a weakness the
pawn on e5 is a weakness so this
position is very very um balanced at the
moment we're going to see who's going to
err first but gary only has two minutes
left so what's going to be that's double
h that's just double-edged position by
the way lavon is trying to milk his
position where he has a big edge on the
clock against sergey kayak he's got 559
to only 46 seconds to move bishop to g4
allowing a queen i mean bishop to g2
excuse me as he could go after this pawn
levon has played the move h4 and this is
queen f1 idea but the king will just
dance and prance all the way out to b2
if you start checking him and meantime
you got mate threats and his queen b8
picking off this pawn on b6 so even if
objectively black is okay and actually
according to the engines it's not so bad
uh he's playing the move k87 after all
that time he has very little time on the
clock and right now is a moment for
lavon not to move quickly but just to
look around for how to keep the tension
keep the challenge in the position you
want your opponent to stop and look at
your moves you don't want to just blitz
out moves because you're forcing him to
make the next move don't just make
concrete threats and then find out that
at the end of it your opponent figured
out how to defend against all of them if
you see a single threat this is the kind
of position where you milk you make him
suffer he's got 49 seconds make him
suffer for a while so you see there
lavon is looking around for that kind of
situation how do i keep the tension
consistent given that i'm the one with
the dominant queen in the middle of the
board a little bit of a semi bluff
because in a classical game in this
position that i have on the board it
just happened a couple of moves ago
after the move king e1
black did have the choice of playing the
move queen e6 trading off those queens
now in a classical game you might be
able to sit down and figure out if the
end game is a draw because it's still
dangerous if you trade queens the bishop
will come to c7 and it will pick up at
least one pawn that might not be enough
to win though that might still be a
drawn end game but you don't have time
as sergey karjakin to sit down and
figure out if you can defend against the
pass pawn on the a file like in that
scenario so he just does the instinctive
way of doing it which is to for now keep
the queens and the ironian had decided
let's force the issue amazing decision
that's not waiting at all he just got
super concrete wouldn't you do this if
you know it's a win as opposed to
continuing the game i think i would have
also milked it a little bit more i feel
like he could always have traded the
queens and i'm not so sure that e1 is
the best place for the king i would at
least like to have it on d2 and i'm not
sure why he did it in this precise
moment but okay here off we go bishop e5
is going to start vacuuming the spawns
on the queen side i think you have to
play b5 at some point you cannot give up
both of the pawns because if you give up
v6 and a5 for free you will also give up
c5 and that's why you got to do it right
now i mean f5 is necessary
that's what his plan was to play the
move c4 of course and now
how do you defend
both pawns
how do you defend against just taking on
a5 and rushing this pawn forward is a
pink problem
because this bishop is locked out you
probably i'm wondering if you can
passive defense this if you take on f5
like you play bishop h3 you take on f5
and you just defend with the bishop on
c8 that might be good enough actually
that's a challenge because also you have
a past pawn yourself coming up on the
other side of the board that you'll
force a king to our bishop to respect so
he will have some play he actually just
played the move kings
f7 right away yeah and
i have the feeling this is just a draw
to be honest and this this is the
problem if it is just a draw in the end
why play like this when the guy has no
time on the clock and you could always
get to a position like this why force
the action when you had such a good
position to start with very surprising
decision
from levon even though his opponent only
has 20 seconds left but the minister of
defense as they call him if there's a
draw he's gonna find it yeah and i have
the feeling that this was as you said a
bit too rushed from levon uh
he had better choices practically in my
opinion hang out didn't you go for this
just hang out why play unless unless he
really did just think i'm winning i'm
gonna win everything this is easy
but it would be a little bit surprising
to me if there was no way to bring the
bishop back to defend i mean it is still
an opposite color bishop end game
because the reality is the path the a
pawn does not fly through
as you mentioned it does not fly all the
way in so here he goes and there's the
defense that we're talking about f6 that
who knows
transferring the advantage to the f file
he's trying to create a weakness on h6
and it does present a problem he said no
thank you
uh g5
what intuition on the part of this
player yeah although i don't really know
if there was a problem with it i don't
think there was either but the point is
you can't play bishop takes a5 without
giving him king f6 so this g-pawn will
be a real pawn
oh i i don't see why white is better
anymore i mean the bishop is going to
come back to c8 i will take exactly
we'll have an extra pawn because he'll
probably take on c5 at some point but
it's more of a symbolic edge yeah how do
you make progress no i think this is
dead but let's take that question of is
white better to the anishigiri fabiano
game anish does have an extra pawn
but that very well poised knight on d5
weren't we just trashing that night a
couple of minutes ago no the knight is
suddenly the best piece on the board but
it's the beauty of chess it changes so
quickly first the first here yeah the
knight on h5 long gone now g5 cementing
the f4 square for his night as well yeah
that's a lot i mean if the question is
white better yeah of course white is
better he's up a pawn he's the only one
with winning chances but that's right it
is not that easy though it's not easy at
all
and it is a blitz game by the way knight
of four minutes
needs to be respected and there's the
knight and there's a rook h8 with a
little bit of matey threats on h1 you've
got to watch out for so pay attention
because black is trying to make some
noise matey
yeah there's some actual counter play
here this is not easy for boyd at all no
and not with the time situation for him
as well 44 seconds when your opponent
has a knight on f4 a rook on d3 the
knight is cemented is a rook h8
possibility your king might get caught
in something you need to spend some time
on the clock and that's what he's doing
now and his seconds are ticking down
precariously as he has to decide does
the guy really have an attack or is it a
bluff and you also have to consider do i
just want to sacrifice my exchange like
play a6 rook h8 take on f4 yeah get rid
of that mating threat that's gonna play
a7 am i fast enough but i don't think so
because rook and rook d7 should catch
the pawn no but also well he goes for it
let's see here it is the other problem
is your knight is hanging on d2 so then
he could just sack for the queen when it
arrived
f3 with real chances as well so and as
we're talking look at him go under 10
seconds this is the problem you got to
calculate a position like this five
seconds is he a where it's four is he
where and he's finally done it yeah he's
getting 10 seconds back and fabi knows
and look at anish now sitting up king to
e2 yeah he wants to prevent this taking
on d2 or f3 he wants to try to create
something with the pawn but threats
immediately rook to d5 man that's the
night before i didn't like root d5 as
much because with knight c4 i don't have
rook a8 because knight v6 will always
kick out my rook that being said rook
takes e5 is a check still a complicated
end game i have a feeling that black is
not that much better like there should
be enough counterplay with the power on
a6 rook to b5 an astute move stopping
the knight from ever going to the the b6
square so he can play a rook a8 but here
comes the king this is going to be
interesting rook b4 at some point oh you
can't even take on f4 because of rook b4
look at that check don't touch my pawn
rook b4 and you're giving up a knight
but it's so s what and the other two
games by the way had been drawn the fun
drew against karjakin that key game
while shaq and antar may have also drew
big decision here after king to e4 does
he want to play for f3 or does he want
to bring rook a8 into the position
immediately this is a tricky position
rook b4 is also tempting because you do
force the king back to d3
well another another big point too many
moves as lavon would say strong players
don't have too many moves this one have
the right move and there are lots of
attractive looking options right now for
black
and not the time to calculate it it also
doesn't feel like anything's actually
winning for black it feels like almost
but i don't see any continuation that
stops the pawn on a6 in a clean manner
by the way is there also a rook d8
but he himself has spent a lot of time
and now he's down to 35 seconds and
ticking so what's the next move and
attacking the knight challenging its
security on that square and that might
just that looks like a7 though
oh no he's decided he's going to keep it
going
96 interesting move where's the night
going next that's the thing it's a
pretty night but it is dominated by the
rooks at the moment so after rook 8.
is there a way to guard the oh you get
to play a7 and you can't attack on b7
this was his point the rook doesn't have
an angle but why not because rook b6 a7
rook c6 check followed by rook c7 you
will have knight b5 b5 will be the big
move the perhaps the knight
remind me of a study i created a couple
of days ago
wow you haven't solved it yet alejandro
but this is this is really familiar
the apon incredible king to c4 now look
at this i like that move quickly king c4
because he saw f6 undermining this
knight and he thought this king must
join the fray
right now
right now the rook
goes down and now it looks like knight
b5 will always happen
black has some poems pawns yeah the
pawns are moving forward and at some
point even if i win that rook for a pawn
if i get my king active and my pawns
moving forward the knight doesn't come
back easily also this rook c8 checker
move here well i guess king v6 is okay
because i will be throwing a8 as white
yeah black black's not queening now
that's key and the white rook is able to
hold you back so
black has to pay attention
yes black still kind of has a draw
whenever he feels like a rook c1 root b1
but
if he pushes forward
it's not easy to see how king b7 is a
real threat though right now king b7 and
knight c7 would be a problem if you
bring your rook all the way back to c8
so right so rook b1 again
is just the repetition whoa there he
goes e4 and now knight c7 and he's gonna
have to sack a rook for the play is it
correct
what a decision
he plays rookie it sacrifices it in oh
he doesn't like oh no that is a
check whoa he's going to pick off those
pawns that's his first key but his king
now but he's going to get cut a little
exposed but he's but he's not mating
there goes the two
and the problem is you can't queen the a
pawn ever
you can't fix
the rest of the pieces can your rook
swing around and help
in the battle and there goes the knight
to e3 what an interesting idea by anish
finding an anchor square on e3 and it's
fabi now who's down on the clock guys
seven seconds
he has been waiting
well he has the perpetual
until you play 93 then it then it
doesn't exist anymore i think you should
just give the perpetual now yeah it
looks like he's gonna have to do it yeah
the idea is that rook fences off the
king so you can just check them at the
time what a game that was wow that was
crazy crazy end game what a draw as
we certainly got our money's worth
without
something that finish was crazy there
might have been a win somewhere but boy
they really played that position if
there was a win i did not see it
it was late
and that was the moment because i was
mentioning that once the knight goes to
e3 suddenly the c4 square is no longer a
check so the king might hide on a4
so fabi just decided take the draw now
and analyze later it was the important
moment to do so i think one more move
and then suddenly you are
running out of the options to finish the
game and without any time on the clock i
think he would have easily lost that end
game i think gave him that perpetual
having that mental 42 saying look the
king is weak but i can't really get to
it stop trying to win finish the game
before it goes south
i love it because you know favi had that
opportunity earlier in the game but he
kept pushing for the way yeah but when
the moment came
it was time and this is a very
interesting moment because after knight
c7 we're kind of so focused on the rook
being won with the promotion of the pawn
that we kind of forget that e6 is
actually hanging
um
but this kind of eliminates any chance
that black can have of winning once you
eliminate the pawns on the king side
even if you win the pawn on a7 for free
it's incredibly difficult to win
and obviously you're not winning that
precious pawn for free i mean that's
going to cost you a rook so it's
important to give the perpetual
immediately a little bit of a lucky
resource if i by the way
24 moves after the g5 move was played
the engine says
great play by both sides awesome chess
simply beautiful moves that led just
basically equal it's shifting maybe some
edge back and forth but not much
beautiful end game play by this oh this
was great this was top level
seconds on the clock i mean absolutely
great
yeah
incredible as we take a look at our
standings those draws will keep our same
trio at the top of the standings between
anish and milan all with three points
one victory in round one followed by a
draw
and of course the rest of the standings
stay the same as well
but fabi
can feel good about
coming back from that game which looked
really difficult um earlier it was an
exciting round but no wins no wins
incredible but a beautifully exciting
round great play
everywhere you looked you saw chances
people going for play i think though the
one person i have to say i'm a little
surprised at the way he handled it was
lavonne
five minutes on the clock i see this
happen a lot with players
even top players they got time on the
clock
your opponent has no time the position's
a little unclear
you could go forcing but if you just
chill for a while and make them suffer
they're going to suffer and potentially
make a mistake instead of doing that you
play more forcing play and then all of a
sudden your advantage is gone and so i'm
surprised at the way levon handled his
business in that game forcing the
position and causing it to just fizzle
pretty quickly but other games
very impressive this last one being
almost at the top of the list we didn't
get a good chance to look at the game
between mamadiarov and artemyev of
course a starfield game but
instead of taking your advice maurice of
playing this b5 idea of the expansion
which i kind of liked he went for the
other tempting option which was to take
on a5 with the idea of breaking himself
on the queen side with a5 later the
problem with this kind of brakes is that
if you don't have enough fuel in the
fire then by the time that you actually
do brake on a5 like it is in this
position it might kind of just reduce
itself to a draw because you didn't
really gain that much from the break you
cannot really put the pawn on a6 at any
point knight v8 will corral it and just
win it so you are kind of
resigned to the fact that eventually
white will suffer b takes a5 and have to
trade all of the pieces off and that
eventually led to a drawn end game
between mamadiarov and or tamiya guys
could we go back to some pure just
boldface genius
i mean this move g5
you you know first be like you can't
play g5 oh i'm playing g5 no you can't
play g5 oh trust me i'm playing g5 okay
all right fine i told you you couldn't
play g5 now i just stole your pawn and
your knight's under attack with check
you thought you were hitting on e2 but
you're not oh you played queen e8 oh i
told you you had to back up
oh oh you got a queen a8 coming wait
wait whoa whoa
wait a second i might get mated if i'm
not careful i mean what is this this the
way anand is playing these retreating
moves with genius that's what i really
enjoy when you start playing those
retreating moves that are masking also
the attacking moves that's when you know
somebody is just seeing the board a
queen on h5
checking out the a8 square
your brain has to be fresh wide open to
be checking a chess board like that and
he is totally on forum right now the
indian fans got to be pleased with what
anand is bringing to the show
and we are christian
christian with fabiano
yes i'm here with number two player in
the world fabiano caruana he needs to
win this tournament in order to be able
to qualify uh to london but fabiano was
shaky start the first game was quite
difficult but the second one it kept us
all on the edge of our seats yeah i
played this very dubious opening and i i
can't say that it's even a variation or
anything i just
got to the board and
wasn't really sure what to play so i
played something which turned out to not
be very good
and i got a very bad position at some
point
but yeah somewhere he started to mess it
up like he was very close to winning at
this point did you see uh did you spot
the move rotates b6 and bishop takes h7
to take the pawn yeah but i mean i
didn't see a better move than rook a5
here
there was not so i mean what can i do
yeah i got into this position and i had
to do something it didn't seem like
losing i mean it seemed bad in general
but were you surprised by his uh yeah
yeah rookie one was surprising um
okay i didn't spot f6 here but
i still thought my position is dubious
but uh at least i'm not losing b6 or
anything i mean the pressure is off b6
especially because he spent so much time
in this position it felt like even
though your knight on h5 is completely
out of play you will still get some sort
of counter play because he has to go g4
to control the knight and then it opens
up the diagonal the king gets a bit weak
well yeah the knight on h5 is not really
out of play
because white has to keep an eye on if
like it's f4 of course
then it becomes very active and very
dangerous so he has to keep an eye on it
so it's sort of it's not a good piece of
course but
it's not fully out of the game uh and of
course at some point it got completely
crazy i mean i was very happy when i got
this ending i thought
i'm
probably going to make a draw here
and then he started to get low on time
and
like i got suddenly got an attack i mean
um
with a low on time it starts to look
very scary for white and so he's acting
exchange which was probably a long time
a practical choice
but i did feel like i was very close to
being winning here it might have just
been the
time that i was giving me that feeling
but like when i
yeah when i played rook b3
uh yeah if he doesn't play king e4 he
loses
maybe i had something better
uh to round up if i get the a pawn of
course then you know
uh but
maybe rupee three was just a panicky
move i saw that king of foursome work
and king e4 looked like tactically
dangerous for him
and so i played it without really i mean
i didn't have enough time to go into all
the details
uh but yeah and then after that i was of
course probably losing at some point
i mean i lost control we were both
getting a little time and i'm sure i was
losing but
with a few seconds you can't
really hope for accuracy well still uh
not a bad game of course the first one
was very difficult what are you going to
do to bounce back in the third one you
have white so
yeah i'm playing wesley uh he's
been doing very well recently um
okay i guess he also had a shaky start
here i probably know what he was hoping
for but i mean anything can happen you
know just the first two games don't
really decide
uh a player's form i think even though
we have had shaky starts we're probably
both relatively optimistic about our
chances in the tournament you guys are
both coming from norway from the
official random finals do you think uh
playing so much visual random will
influence your game
probably not i mean well here i guess
the first two games i was sort of in a
random mode in the first game i played a
very
uh
enterprising but very risky line i
didn't
just backfired on me uh okay you saw
this game so so my first two games were
anything but solid and uh
i don't i don't really think it had
anything to fish around but maybe
okay we'll let you go back to your
preparation good luck in uh next game
thanks
guys back to you
thank you and uh what a what a round
what a start here to the super bed as it
seems like a lot of players in good form
yeah uh we haven't seen that many
blunders a couple here and there i think
sergey has specially been in bad form
not taking advantage of the positions he
has been given especially this last one
against aronian having such a pleasant
position
the blunder of the pawn didn't see it
and then slowly getting pushed
out of the board i mean he did make a
draw at the end but sergey was under
pressure from a position that he was the
one that should have been pushing with
the pair of bishops the control of the
e-file and the opposite happens so i'm
not very happy about sergey's form at
the moment but we've some some great
games on other boards
and we do have christian with an
interview with boris becker
i'm here with six-time grand slam winner
and one of the youngest to ever do it at
the wimbledon boris becker a legend of
the sport boris welcome back to
bucharest tell us about your first
impressions here at the stageari country
club the venue the playing hall the
players because you've met already some
of them i'm a big fan of romania of
bukharashi in particular you know way
back when i met mr yonteriak and his
family
became embedded into romania so it's
always good for me to come back
but i'm in particular proud to be
invited
to the superbad
tournament here at stationary country
club uh it's uh in a lustrous group of
grand masters i'm surrounded with i
played a quick game of chess with
fabiano carrozzo
and uh
i'm honored to be you know promoting
such an important tournament i know
you've played uh some of the best chess
players in the world you've attended a
lot of chess tournaments white chess
chess is very similar to tennis it's a
man against man
not the first move but the last ball
counts
you need to be very patient a lot of
strategy
a lot of
mind games going on on a chess board on
a tennis court
and ultimately you're on your own you
are responsible for everything you do so
very similar lifestyle it's very similar
mentality and ever i met gary kasparov
25 years ago i became a big fan and i
got to play with him as well don't ask
who won
so i became a big fan of chess we often
hear a lot of the tennis players take
cues from chess players but what can
chess players take from tennis players
in terms of strategy in terms of
preparation psychological edge i think
it's always important to find your
identity how how you are what's your
comfort zone how you want to play
because it's always bad to adapt too
much to your position your position has
to adapt to your style and i think
that's what the top tennis players do so
well and probably the top chef players
as well so whoever wants to be good you
have to find your own signature
an important initiative of the superbad
foundation is to bring chess to the
younger generations
you
yourself have taught your kids how to
play chess why do you think it's so
important teach them at a young age
chess as tennis gives young people
the experience of
learning a lot of life skills about you
know fair play
about patients about strategy about math
geometry all these things that you need
to so much later in life regardless
whether they become a professional or
not so the earlier you can start the
better you will be i know you've played
gary castro of nigel short but who is
the strongest tennis player that you
faced over the chess board there are a
couple of good ones around
i'd like to think i'm one of the best
tennis players
i don't remember a loss yet but then i
don't play every tournament but
hopefully i can promote that in the
tennis circles as well we've had one of
the most memorable matches of tennis
this year at wimbledon when novak
djokovic
upset roger federer
how did you see that match from the
stands as a chess player
very much so one of the best matches of
tennis i've seen you know two
players at their peak playing the very
best at the most important tournament
what more do you want and i
it for five hours on top of it uh but
novak is a big chess player as well uh
we played a lot of chess together he's
very strategic on the court he knows
exactly which point to do at what score
and i think that's what makes him win
[Music]
hey
hello and welcome back to the grand
chester coverage of super bet in
bucharest romania let's take a look at
our standings after two rapping games
we've got three heavy hitters at the top
of the field vishyanan anishikuri and
levon aronian
two players in very good position
especially if they keep playing like
this to qualify for london anis really
needs to win first here to give himself
good chances yeah even that still
requires him to do well in the next
tournament so it's not like he wins this
one and is qualified but
he had a very nice game in the first
round this one's not so clean he did get
such a promising position against
fabiano carona in round two that night
on h5 just making a very bad impression
but he wasn't able to convert it let's
see if he can do so in the next round
but
we have to talk about the all-american
matchup that's right a huge game here
fabi versus wesley both of these players
really needing a w
um to keep their chances of an american
and our chances of an american london
happy
yeah i mean
must win
games for foreign coming up
just has to put the points together if
he doesn't he can say goodbye to his
london dreams some of the other
important pairings i particularly want
to see the wild card a matchup between
artemia and korvo i think we haven't
given them their deserved attention
although they haven't played the most
interesting games so far this is going
to be i think a key one but of course
vishyana against shakuyama medyarov can
visually keep up his good streak of play
against somebody that has not been able
to pick himself up in the grand chess
tour he has had some good tournaments
this year he went far in the world cup
he won the one of the grand prix but
mamadiarov has not done well at all in
the grand chess tour so far this is
looking boyish i'm sorry he's looking
sprightly fresh ready i don't know
what's in that water he's drinking but
he is uh looking like he's here to play
he's playing like a vichyanan of old
just dropping down some really fresh
moves very alert clock time issues
forget about it he is just looking so
good who picked fishy to win i did
yeah you saw that first after round
wow no credit thank god get out of here
that was that was impressive that what
he's done so far let's see if we can
keep it up though because it's not just
about day one it's about
day five right i mean it's only two
rounds it's only two rounds there's so
much chess going on we have nine rounds
of rapid eighteen of blitz absolutely so
much less
but all the players are so tightly
bunched up there at the pod the top it
really makes sense from a logical point
of view to pick somebody who's won the
first game right i mean like stop it
stop it
all of you were ready to jump on the
wesley so bandwagon yeah tilly lost the
first yes exactly no i'm the only one
who stuck true to my colors i said i was
going to pick karjakin and i did but
it's not like kayaking laws
that's true
the reason i picked him was because of
blitz it's all about him staying stable
now i don't really care about what he
does now as long as he doesn't get in a
hole that's my biggest worry every time
karjakin is like at 50
then instantly he becomes a threat so if
he can just stay cool maybe plus one out
of the first nine rounds then he turns
into a monster in the second part let's
see what he can do right now the st
louis rapid and blitz as he perhaps is
thinking the exact same thing you are
maurice
yeah we'll see he still has to survive
this part though he's not been
historically great in rapid chess
and already an open sicilian opens his
own
probably going to be some sort of naido
fest that is what i think anish plays
when he goes for the sicilian
uh let's take a look pretty sharp it's
not his usual type of e4 e5s that he
specializes no dracula
well it's still early to call it
it does have a draw now under his belt
and of course we do see the night or as
predicted but that was one of the
hardest spot draws or could have been
and i think that
it is it is something that anish is
aware of you know winning this
tournament keeps his chances alive um in
the grand chester and why not why not go
for it
yeah i mean i had mentioned this earlier
as long as there's some kind of ray of
hope they will cling onto it very
traditional way of playing this naidor
for sergey karakanap variation that has
exploded in the last couple of years
this retreat of the knight to f3 instead
of b3 which was the old way of playing
uh i'm not going gonna say that it's
overtaking the main line but i think
everybody's played like this with bishop
e3 and knight of three at least a couple
of times this year did he just get up
like we're just in the opening why why
is anish already walking away from the
chess board uh i mean you just you just
play bishop v6 the guy's probably going
to play another move right he's probably
just pacing right now i'm actually not
really sure because i've looked
extensively in this variation and i've
never looked at bishop e6 don't remember
how far is he going to walk it's not
like he's racing oh he's coming back
he's back back to the board sorry i
thought he was quickly going in the
other direction but okay but why is he
that confident i play bishop e6 and i
walk away your turn that's
that's interesting in a rapid game so
what are the things that you like better
about having that i don't know
that's a good question why did you put
the knight on f3 rather than on b3 and
the real answer is that
you want to play bishop c4 and when the
knights on b3 and you play bishop c4
once i play b5 you don't have squares
and the positives of having the knight
on b3 over f3 of course is that it
leaves the f pawn open to play f3
gracefully defending both the e4 pawn
and against knight g4 threats right
although a big plus of having the knight
on b3 as opposed to f3 although f3 is a
little bit of a committal move here
normally after knight f3 uh
white is trying to short castle usually
you don't see this long castle plays and
then you don't really want to play f3 it
kind of weakens your dog's course
instead you're trying to uh play for the
d5 square and in that sense then i don't
have three might look a little bit
offside but you have to make some sort
of concession as white and it's not a
huge one putting the knight on f3 it can
remaneuver to some good squares knight
d2 knight f1 knight e3 is one way knight
h4
knight f5 is a common way as long as g6
is not really playable so there are ways
to get the knight back into the game
it's not a great square on f3 but
basically you're saying that all of my
other pieces are quite good by the way
we have some more moves bishop e3 knight
e7
castle's short as you mentioned we don't
we're not really looking to castle
queenside now that we have our knight on
f3
and rook c8 played
and this is just a typical knight of
structure in which white has better than
usual control over d5 but has spent some
tempo to do so i've been told that eight
times we've reached this position
according to the database and tell me
why black doesn't play for knight g4 in
these positions so like for instance
instead of rook c8
either move knight g4 in this position
um it doesn't help your position very
much if i just move the bishop somewhere
like for example if i retreat it to c1
or to d2 right does this knight can be a
tactical issue because the only defender
is currently being attacked i can always
take on e6 i move my knight somewhere
but the knight just doesn't do anything
on g4 and if i were to go back to f6 now
you would just switch it up and you
wouldn't you wouldn't go for the draw
you would play some other useful move
here yeah very logically i would play
the bishop g5 yeah because i want to
eliminate one of the defenders of the d5
square and unless this has a tactical
drawback i will take on f6 and then
establish something on d5
and christian with his thoughts on round
three of the rapid
well we definitely have a very big uh
game and that is the one between fabiano
and wesley and we got this team opening
of course the joko piano but wesley has
been asking this idea of king h8 knight
g8 f5 to blast open uh the position on
the king's side d4 fabian was definitely
prepared he was playing allah temple
blitzing every single move knight to g8
b4 now this is a big sacrifice and a
very very concrete move because after he
takes d4 c takes d4 knight takes b4 now
i'm just simply the upper pawn
y plays a5 f6 knight to c3 knight to e7
of course is it looks like you don't
really have a lot of pieces next to your
king you only have the knight and of
course the rook but the rook is not the
great defender and white will try to
shift his pieces on the on the king side
he played the move knight to e2
preparing to go to either f4 or g3 most
likely he's going to go to f4 and then
potentially jump to e6 or shift his
direct direction towards the g7 square
via knight h5 white has a lot of options
on the other hand he is still up down a
pawn and if the black knight from b4
comes back into play and potentially
gets closer to the king like knight to
g6 and then if you move knight to g3
then come back with uh with the knight
knight to c6 knight to e7 bring the
second knight close to the king
this could turn uh in into a slugfest
and you don't if you don't find the
compensation as white
you will end up just down the pawn this
is going to be a very interesting one um
i'm not sure who who i prefer in this
position but definitely we should keep
an eye on it
i think christian of course this is a
position that we have seen before as we
have already analyzed this in the game
between maxine vasherla graf and wesley
saw himself in the sink field cup
earlier this year
which if i remember correctly fizzled
into a draw
so instead we have a very quick d5 break
here by wesley trying to tactically
solve his issues
it does make some sense to throw in the
move d5 when you can on the other hand
you kind of have to be worried about the
squares that it leaves undefended
it does
feel that allowing this was a bit of a
weird decision by fabi could he have
played something better than knight e2
that's why that's what i'm saying
because i think 92 was the novelty right
if yes we get the check on that knight
e2 but he must have
known right and checked that d5
is the immediate move and he has
something in mind otherwise you don't
allow this move
d5 just to appear on the board
yeah this is a little bit curious
because
unless i have something tactical with my
bishops like bishop a3 is actually
threatening something besides bishop
takes d5 which i can cover from easily
where is my compensation lying in right
now because now that i don't have the
pawn structure in the center black has
all the squares that he needs to finish
the development of his pieces especially
with this bishop coming to f5 so white
is under the pressure of
putting his pieces in a way that black
cannot easily develop his pieces
and there you go bishop a3 was played
uh i should mention that we are very
lucky here that we have some phenomenal
russian commentaries here as well in
studio here in saint louis mele kachion
and ilya schmiren are
manning that stream so if you speak
russian you're in luck it's his first
time ilya came in here and
said yeah never been in the studio
looked around
so he liked it he liked it good to
welcome him aboard hillary smearing of
course one of the great players i
remember playing him way back in the day
and we were always in awe of his
incredible play king of the world opens
he used to play and of course
now here we see sergey
you know it's amazing it's round three
all the tension to play for and these
guys are just casually walking around
like a day in the park no big deal i'm
not being hunted down by one of the
greatest players of our generation that
was a beautiful shot there though shout
out to uh to kevin or
the whole team
over in london not in london in romania
i'm shooting on site what is going on
because this last move knight h4 is
actually quite provocative uh and knight
c5 was the answer were you worried about
knight e4 but then there's a d6 pawn
hanging in the end right right you
cannot take on e4 with this discovery
because you have to go further than that
on the tactics knight takes e4 bishop
takes h4 and of course knight takes d6
and you want a much more important pawn
plus the work on c8 is hanging i think
that's kind of the main issue but of
course after knight c5 i'm not really
sure how he's planning to defend this
pawn because this doesn't work as well
like if i defend f3 i think i take c4
now you can take it because
um after knight takes e4 you take the
the knight and this line doesn't work
out the same way but there there's still
some issues there's still some issues
between this position maybe between h5
between g4 is stronger
not so easy
yeah
but we have some news in the fobby game
with maurice
big time news but computer-esque
variation to prove it will he find this
line fabiano has a tremendous move right
now queen b3 look at these pieces
pressuring along the long diagonal looks
like it's easy to resolve c6
tie everything down what are you
supposed to do continue the pressure
with knight to c3 hitting this knight
multiple times and here's the trick if
knight takes c3 trying to solve the
problem this amazing intermezzo bishop
to f7
good luck finding this line this is just
such a beautiful move the point being to
pressure the rook which of course is
defending this knight now if you drop
your knight back to try to say well i'll
get two pieces for the rook no can do
after bishop takes these seven knight
takes and the one move queen e7 and you
have no queen e3 and you have no way of
guarding the e7 square you're just going
to drop material here an amazing line
beautiful tactically certainly a
computer s line fabi finds that i'd be
very impressed as this of course he has
a lot of time on the clock so he can
start with the move and maybe he'll
notice the idea but it's absolutely
brilliant i think the hard part part of
this variation is not so much to figure
out that bishop f7 works but what is
knight c3 threatening because you could
say that you're taking on d5 but that
just recovers the pawn
and it doesn't seem like he has that
much of a clear intention for example
let's go back on your line queen b3 c6
knight c3 i get this and knight c3 loses
to bishop f7 but if i just i guess
that's the problem
i just what like what is black's move
here and the other issue that's one
issue and your b7 is hanging
tremendously if you try and he didn't
see it now g3 no surprise and also
there's also the key move after the c6
move alejandro that line uh the idea
being the threat of well it's knight c3
the idea being
the threat of putting your knight on e4
and also dropping on d6
and that is a normal for example a rook
b8 move right now not realizing the
danger might walk into a knight e4 and
the knight is headed to that d6 square
so suddenly there's threats out of
nowhere that could be just demolishing
your position so the danger is present
such a deep danger to notice in fact
that it's no surprise that he played a
more positional move just didn't spot
that line at all and played a more
positional move and played knight to g3
no it's a more logical move because it's
consistent with the move knight e2 you
don't play knight e2 to return to c3 you
play 92 to maneuver the knight to g3 and
then another issue seeing reversing our
ideas as humans just not easy to do no
knight g3 still looks very logical to me
white does have more compensation than i
thought especially with the knight on g3
i was mentioning the easy way to develop
the pieces for black but it takes away
this important f5 square without the f5
square i'm not really sure how to
continue development for black of course
bishop f5 blunders a piece i think
bishop takes d5 is the way to do so and
the knight is overloaded defending the
bride on d5 and the bishop on f5 you
cannot take with the queen because the
knight
yeah it's hanging
so not so easy to develop for wesley
because again the move c6 leaves this
opposition on d6 weakened so i don't
voluntarily want to play this either
you're kind of not exactly zug's wong
but you're kind of left wondering what
black's next move is
i'm actually not sure at all like this
really seems unpleasant the more i look
at it yeah perhaps the computer
preferred queen b3 and knight t3 because
it was a very direct concrete approach
but i also think knight g3 puts a lot of
pressure on the position here for wesley
so i i like from a practical point of
view to play white
yes i understand
that that would be an important we're
hearing that bishop d7 is a possibility
here it looks weird because it obviously
takes some protection away from the
knight on d5 but at the moment
um
it's headed to c6 though no clear
tactical way to exploit that bishop b7
just no i understand i understand you're
happy if you that bishop gets to c6 but
you also have a king side to worry about
i'm starting to look at knight h4 and
queen h5 and i'm not really sure i'm
doing that much but i'm a little bit
scared about putting the bishop on c6
because it does control this important
knight on d5 and it cements this
blockade and we always talk about the
blockade against the isolated queen
spawn but
there's a lot of diagonals that are
weakened on the on the king side i got
knight h4 queen h5 bishop d3
knight f4 there's a bishop there's a
bishop b5 though there's a bishop e5 as
well not just bishop c6 but as a bishop
b5 making sure that bishop gets uh
neutered if you will so that we don't
have to watch this piece go crazy like
you suggested alejandro so knight h4
bishop b5 would be the move ah bishop b5
that's kind of important because i was
getting a little bit scared here the
bishop c6 queen h5 but if you have
bishop b5 then this is a better way of
doing things of course you want to trade
off this light squared bishop and the
other reason that i like mission b7 is
because i don't see another mover
i mean i don't know what else to do
you could play something like c6 and
cover up with bishop b8 but
it is
it is something i could consider i just
don't like putting my pieces so
passively
and let's talk a look at the wild cards
we do have that game going on between
them as wesley does play the move bishop
d7 between vladis love artemyev and
antoine korobot
not the most fascinating game that we've
seen a symmetrical groomfield fiance
grunfeld where it does feel like white
has generated a modicum amount of
pressure that's a bit a little bit of a
better knife that's played knight e5
threatening bishop takes d5
yeah i assume that this pawn will be
defended uh by taking on e5 taking on e5
and retreating the bishop to e6 i don't
want to play e6 because that kind of uh
self traps you traps the bishop and i
think this just actually went in piece
you probably will defend with bishop on
e6 but usually black is very solid and
it's difficult to create any kind of
threats because if i for instance play
rook
i'm thinking like if i play rook d1 and
queen d2
yeah you can you can definitely pile on
but
it's usually not going to be enough to
actually ever win the pawn because with
the rook on d8 i should have enough
defenders
a little bit more pleasant for white but
nothing really special going on in this
position right and
looking at another game between shaq and
anand is maurice i'm having a flashback
and i'm wondering if anan is having the
same flashback do you remember the
singfield cup we just saw this this game
uh that we were talking about with with
wesley but the sinkfield cup where anan
had this wonderful position
was it also a double king pawn opening
as well against mamadirov
in that he also had a beautiful game
where he was just crushing shaq and then
all of a sudden tractor said uh what
about this and what about this and
confuse you with that and poof and all
of a sudden anna got flustered backed up
instead of pressing his initiative and
so much initiative it became for
shakriyah that he ended up drawing the
game well this one he has a nice little
position that's anand you can play in
the movement he doesn't have anything to
write home about necessarily but it
moved like knight c4 play a little bit
aggressively he played knight f1 and
chakra said nope i'd like to mix it up
with you let's get busy the move d5
knight takes take takes and now knight
takes e4 bishop takes e4 d takes e4 and
you could trade down if you like but in
that game i remember specifically the
move queen h5 featured as a star in that
game and now anand plays it yet again in
this position so we're seeing a little
bit of
mirroring of their game just a couple of
months ago in the sink field cup anand
trying to press for something small here
he has given up the bishops but he is
somebody who gives up bishops liberally
he prefers knights over bishops in games
most of the time so yes he's giving up
the light square bishop now we've seen
this position on the board a queen on
8-6 sniffing around a king but is it
enough
compensation
compensation for
for the two bishops
i just don't know i mean
the idea of rook h5 does feel pretty
dangerous to me
if i saw this visually it wouldn't be my
impression that white has anything if
anything i would think that they're on
the back end because queen f6 is coming
rook h5 is kind of a threat i love this
bishop on v6
maybe on a deeper level
it's possible to say that i will play
bishop e3 and the knight is better than
the light scored bishop well it turns
out it turns out that in this position
the engines hate black literally hate
black because of hate black can you
believe it well g6 queen takes h6 was
the culprit and after rook takes e5 the
move knight g3 guarding against the one
threat that rook check the rook to uh h5
idea hitting this pawn preparing bishop
to e3 and shutting down the dark squares
and you can start to see a bit of a
problem happening as this bishop on c8
is starting to become a little anemic
while this knight has the potential to
jump around especially
what is the answer to queen f6 is to
just take on e4 and say i'm running with
the king queen of six is bishop to f4
of course yeah first and then here comes
the other rook and e4 is hanging e4 is
hanging i forgot about that big problems
here so queen uh after this move rook
takes e5 if anand finds this one
what we'd say duversky would call the
prophylactic move just stop not rook h5
completely and he has found it and he
has found it it's on the board and anan
back in business according to the
engines at least and now as we look at
it a little bit longer we're realizing
this is dangerous for black pieces are
going to erupt i just didn't realize of
the move bishop by far the queen f6
would solve all black's problems but
without this resource and of course
knight g3 preventing rook h5 but more
importantly threatening 94 just winning
the game
leaves black with some real problems to
solve because i don't know how you you
comfortably uh solve this issue because
e4 is hanging and how do i defend this
guy and remember with like queen e7 or
something the problem is seven kind of
runs into things because i can start
kicking you around bishop f4 probably
rookie six not not a move i wanted to
play
and then even bishop g5
are you playing queen eight or
what is the move here queen eight is
such a sad move and your bishop on c8 is
blocked your rook on eight is not coming
in the game the white rook on d even on
a1 is coming to d1 i mean it's just lots
of easy player
flow happening on the board for anan
once again he's showing that fantastic
style
that fantastic form at least on day one
now we've seen day one performers before
we've seen fantastic before i remember
fabi did great was it the last rapper in
blitz where he just ran out of the gates
really quickly on day one and we're like
whoa look at fabi and then on day two i
think he might have cooked scored 50 and
then day three fell off the cliff so
let's not be uh
too enthusiastic too over exuberant
although i'm kind of getting that way
right now watching anand play because
he's just playing such great chess
looking like the world champion
five-time world champion at that right
now
really good position for white liking it
and he's ahead on the time again as
usual um and here we have the sandy's in
the grand chess tour as we see why this
event is so important for players like
lavonne
for for wesley for fobby certainly as
they try to make the final four in
london meanwhile i had a question about
this idea of giving up a bishop four
night in the game between fabian wesley
as the move bishop d7 was played and you
guys were saying
knight h4 bishop b5
right so how about if at that moment
i play um
bishop takes e7 with the idea of bishop
f7 and queen h5
let's take a look on the board
the suggestion is
that after knight h4 bishop b5 i take on
e7
i
pretty sure that can i think with the
rook
actually with the rook it's kind of
dangerous because of queen h5 ideas but
okay let's take with the knight it looks
a little bit more natural and so i was
about seven and come up in another
and then queen h5 and i just have a lot
of pieces crawling over here so
rookie seven of course is the immediate
threat with the idea of knight g6 um
winning the queen but wait a second what
what was taking with the rook what maybe
maybe thinking with the rook is just
better move i don't know yeah uh here in
this position rook takes bishops anyways
this should be five i would just stick
with the rook here yeah okay yeah that
might actually solve some problems
because if i have to allow bishop f7 i
might run into issues okay so yeah
because i was trying to get that extra
piece into the attack now
queen h5 immediately just runs into what
bishop takes c4 right or rook takes c1
c1 and then
one and bishop c4 and then we just have
lots of people yeah let me just show
this because there it seems dangerous
but it's just a check and i don't see
any continuation because here e8 is
covered by the two pieces i don't have
any problems there knight g6 checking g8
really seven is covered g7 is copyright
there and your knight is now actually
hanging and there's no forward there's
no yeah there's just not enough fuel in
this fire as far instead has played the
move queen b3 it kind of stops to move
bishop b5 but
unless tactically i wanted to get to
this position i would have much rather
played queen b3 first yep because the
bishop is now going to establish itself
on c6
and it has
been playing very fast doesn't make any
sense for white to have gone for this
move order if you had to play queen b3
yeah he didn't prevent this idea but he
played rookie four
quickly on the board rookie four i like
rookie four that's a boss type move even
if i'm a little bit scared but he must
have looked at it when he spent those
minutes thinking
obviously rookie 4 it's it's allowing
any discovery by that knight on d5
whenever you have to do something like
that you want to look around but he said
i looked around enough i don't think you
have any night move that bothers me and
my rook is on this great square rookie
tour of running tonight at four but
rookie four prevents that and prepares
to double so
really sharp move of picking up the
intensity in this game i love the idea
because rook h4 and this continuous
attack on the king said just never gets
better for wesley we talked earlier
about the misplacement of one piece
being enough to attack on the other side
and it's bishop on a7 by wesley that is
currently not doing anything yeah it's
pressure in d4 but you're never going to
take that part i'm not going to let you
it's just not participating in the
defense of the king side and that is
practically a tough thing to solve let's
take a look at some of the other games
when uh but before that let's go to
bucharest with christian carrillo
thank you alejandro yes i've been
watching this game develop the game
between karjakin and geary because giri
is simply transforming as a player we've
seen in the european team championship
he was playing some wild stuff he
usually uh two three years ago he was
you know doing the berlin doing the
petrov as black now he's going for
najdorf he's going for the throat and
this is exactly what's happening he's in
good shape in this position
we have a typical night or
unfortunately for white he doesn't
really have a clear plan and the knight
on h4 is a little bit out of the way
queen to d7 was played and g3 was a huge
mistake now
this is an excusable mistake because
white is trying to come up with a plan
and his plan is to go knight to g2
knight to e3 knight to d5 and create
that fourth res on the on the square d5
the problem is he's too slow castle
knight to g2 and this bishop d8 maneuver
bishop v8 bishop a5 challenging the
knight on c3 is huge and it gives black
the advantage i think sergey simply just
missed this after queen d3 bishop a5
rook ad1
rook to d8 this is simply just
dominating for black i'm going to take
on c3 i'm going to double up on the c
file and you're going to have a huge
weakness on the pawn on c3 the pawn on
a2 potentially if i manage to displace
the bishop from from b3 so this just
looks amazing for black white doesn't
really have any way of creating counter
chances on the king side if you start
pushing your pawns with f4 then you're
just simply going to weaken your own
king so i see giri as a clear favorite
in this game back to you
well i'll take it christian and
this position by
vishy looking so sweet as he's forced
his opponent on the back foot and chakra
played the move queen to e8 now
vichy did miss a bit of a stronger move
with bishop to g5 in this position he
played the move bishop to f4 instead you
can hardly blame him because this move
hits a rook that's a tempo free move
move your rook off the square although
he was threatening bishop at six with
the last move but this move hits the
rook and now the rook comes in this is
pure flow here this is just playing
rapid chess off feel and instinct and
making sure you keep the lead on the
clock and the beautiful thing about this
position
look at white's pieces actually what's
not beautiful about the position two
rooks to develop knight on g3 attacking
a pawn bishop on f4 could pounce at any
time queen sniffing around your king on
eight six in the meantime what about
black's pieces defensive queen defensive
rogue blocking a bishop this rook is
saying when am i ever going to get
invited to the party the dark square is
a weak white is simply got lots of
threats that he's looking at right now
vishy in complete command of this
position now this is where
he had shaq against the rope back at the
sink field cup when shaq sacked the pawn
with b5 and went nuts if i remember
correctly
will shaq be able to do something
similar here and just hunker down and
say look i'm not going to let you get
wild on me i've defended against you
before
well he has played the move bishop d7
does that
it doesn't give up a pawn right i cannot
take on e4 i just need to make sure of
that if i take on e4 e1 is hanging at
the end yeah i think i think e1 is
hanging with like basically checkmate
because it's starting to look dangerous
like i have a lot of pieces but after
queen e1 bishop takes f2 it's actually
black that is checkmating first because
i don't know how far real thread has
widened this position so i actually made
it i cannot take on e4 i probably have
to improve my position somehow
not really seeing a clear way of doing
so though this was the imprecision
bishop g5 which was stronger this is
where that move bishop f4 gained the
tempo
well by attacking something but bishop
g5 threatened something to gain that
tempo that bishop f6 idea and so this is
where white is slightly off because now
the engine is giving the move bishop to
g5 as the best move
yeah that's a tough move to make which
you already started bishop you put the
vision on f4 you know humans we don't
like the hiccup and that's what that
bishop f4 bishop g5 move would be as he
now is starting to look for concrete
measures to approach the position and
even if he sees bishop g5 then you have
to say to yourself i mean mission if i
played it first it must be a surprising
move to me
i think h4 looks natural unless there's
something actually wrong with this move
you just push h4h5 and see what happens
and h4 according to the engine is a very
nice looking move as well so
he's got the position he's got the dark
squares he's got the e pawn you have to
play f5 in order to cement your pawn the
engine might even want to give away an
e3 just throw the pawn to the wolves to
try to trade off on the e3 square and
give you an extra pawn but not have to
deal with this attack that's screaming
at you yeah also a difficult move to
make because that makes a permanent
concession
whereas with h4 you can kind of feel
that you probably finish development and
then your position is not so desperate
to just chuck a pawn like that
that being said maybe e3 is just a way
to do it
give up a pawn and say let's simplify
the position i'll hold on to a worse end
game yep that is what these players do
they make it so hard for you to defeat
them and ana now
really sort of for the first time
for the whole day
slowing down
we've seen him play so fast first two
rounds and even the beginning of this
one but now it looks like he slowed down
and
you know
he's feeling he's feeling it and let's
see
he's played the positional bishop to e3
yeah
certainly i was mentioning earlier this
fight of the night against the bishop
and if i can get my
knight to fight against the light square
bishop then i do have some possibilities
of attacking your dark squares i don't
think that shakuya will be so
uh
helpful in exchanging the bishops i kind
of expect
to not trade the bishops to either move
the bishop out of the diagonal maybe
even play c5 anything that's not give up
the bishop i really don't want to trade
c5 is a little bit weird though i don't
really like c5
because it gives up the d5 square maybe
i have this maneuver 92 knight at 495.
yeah surprisingly difficult here for
black while we see vichy continuing his
great day here as he looks to have an
edge on the position and the clock
against shaq and he's at the top of the
leaderboard tied with anishin lavon
after two rounds looking to go into day
two with a very happy score speaking of
anish what weren't we very happy with
this position i think christian left us
off in something quite promising
sicilian looked really sweet well let's
take a look type of sicilian to make you
quit the berlin forever
yeah no that's never going to happen
that that guy's playing the berlin the
rest of his life don't get too excited
yeah but
this looks pretty pretty great i mean
this knight didn't manage to reach e3
which is very important had the knight
reached e3 then this position is a
completely different evaluation but with
this crippled pawn structure it seems
like white is just barely holding on he
does have the pressure on d6 to
compensate so it's not easy to swing
heavy pieces on to attack c3 but
obviously better just a better pawn
structure better everything but
making headway is not so clear in this
position to me
and by the way it's
so
hard to beat the top players you know
you see a lot of draws in chess and we
decry it we don't want it
reason why because these players are so
difficult to be just when you think
you're getting some energy just when you
think you're getting a grip they just
play a move and you go well there it
went and we saw this move rookie four
very sharp there's no natural discovery
for this knight this rook is going to
double white's trying to get some energy
of course we didn't like this knight on
g3 as he could have done it a bit
differently and here was they said i'm
going to take advantage of this moment
i'm going to play b5
hitting your bishop on c4 and
now if your bishop leaves he's happy to
see that happen but this capture and now
knight takes and showing the minus to
this rook hitting the e4 square he was
forced to play bishop e7 rook takes
trade-off pieces and he grabbed this
pawn getting his pawn back remember he
was up upon before was black and now
bishop to d5 queen to c3 played and now
the move rook to d8 and wesley is saying
what do you have the bishop on d5 is now
the lord of the position and even though
this construction looks a little bit
strange with the bishop on a7 and knight
on b6 that can be fixed quite soon by
moving this night and what does white
have in the position he just simply has
no real edge to get his action going so
wesley looks like he solved most of his
problems that doesn't mean this one's a
draw by any means but it certainly looks
like the complications have simply
dissipated looks like a really nicely
played game by wesley meanwhile you were
asking about this anish game
uh because of any looking like he's
trying to catapult himself to two
victories uh i'm wondering about piling
up on the sea fawn by defending v6 with
the knight like how are you going to
meet that
let's go back to this position you want
to play
i want to like pile up on the c pawn and
then play 98 at the right moment and i'm
asking how you're going to defend your c
pawn as i defend my depon
that's an excellent question i don't
really know especially after the last
move queen e2 which seems to release a
little bit of the tension of d6
uh basically the plan is to put the
knight on e8 cement this guy and put
everybody in the c file
and then just take on c3 yeah exactly
and i think that was the idea behind b5
just fixing that pawn on c3 although you
know not like it's going to be much
safer on c4 to be honest no i have the
feeling that you're just eventually
going to lose the pawn on c3 i think
white has to hold on and get some kind
of material uh compensation composition
for his material by putting the knight
on e3 and taking control of the d5
square i
i'm not really sure black is just better
i mean that's what happens when you have
such a horrible pawn structure is that
eventually you kind of run out of
resources to actually hold on to the
pawn
this is why they're called permanent
weaknesses because
black does eventually get its position
to be better and when that happens
gradually the ponson c3 and c2 don't
improve they just don't have a method to
do so and it's not kind of surprising to
me that after 98 which i kind of missed
earlier
just picks up a pawn because it's
immense d6 and that allows the freedom
of the other pieces to jump into the
game a lot of the times making one of
your pieces bad
to make an important task and to free
the others is not a bad decision in
class 98 makes a lot of sense
and don't forget that when we do win
that c pawn suddenly bishop takes b3 and
invading on c2 is going to be in the air
as well so huge difficulties here for
sergey karjakan yeah and you can tell
that on the clock i mean this position
should not have been this complicated
for white to figure out and he's so far
down on the clock only in move 20. is it
too early to start needling marty's like
wait whose pick was sergey again well
i'm not worried about the rapids so yeah
whatever you like i did pick him uh but
the rapid he always sucks i mean i just
i just take that for granted let's see
that if he can just get 50
i just need him to do okay in the rapid
now if he's gonna totally tank and go
like minus three then there's gonna be a
problem but if he can break even or plus
one
my money is in the long game game with
a4 day five when he plays blitz like a
monster he's going what like eight out
of nine once
even
this year was rapid and blitz he also
had a lackluster rapid and ended up he
and you young yi ended up just quick
that's the storyline that's a storyline
i'm just hoping that in this event well
i'm not really hoping i don't i have to
pick so i i actually would love to see
anan qualify as mentioned before and
he'll be a great qualifier i'd like to
see something for something spectacular
like fabi winner you know that would be
amazing
as well and have an american in london
yet again but in terms of my pick for
sergey it's really about him
doing okay in this phase of the
competition because his blitz game is
just superb now
the game with vichy was a game i wanted
to make a point about is vishi is sort
of
not letting uh not using his advantage
as much as he should have as we did see
that move c5 appear on the board b3 and
then c4 two quiet moves
saying i'm cementing something over here
but what did i really get out of it the
knight is better than the bishop for the
moment but it's not going anywhere
itself so this position is certainly
advantageous for white but he's kind of
slow played it he's he's pro he's
pretending or hoping that his advantage
will sustain itself over the long term
but it doesn't seem as though he's quite
knocking on the door just yet another
point i'd like to make is this event has
players who are so close to each other
in strength you know when you walk into
a tournament you usually look around for
the big dogs who do you think is a
favorite who's going to definitely win
well we had challenged ourselves trying
to pick and i'm sure the players also
came in and said
i don't see magnus anywhere i don't see
naka anywhere to really challenge me i
don't see maxine vashila grav anywhere
i mean i think i don't see dingle wren
in the building i mean those are the
people you'd be like i'm scared of those
folks they could really put some numbers
together you look at these guys all of
them are thinking
i could win even though even the wild
cards i think
maybe not all of them but yeah i think
all of the players probably would think
i have chances to place play in the top
three as you look at a field that is
just no completely dominant no question
about it guaranteed to win because he's
got so much game players in this
tournament yeah and that's a great point
maurice because i think that if maxine
had known that this field would lack
magnus and nakamura maybe this would
have been one of the events to play
well
maybe but i i don't think he actually
has fear of anybody when it comes to the
rapid time controls i think he's happy
with here with his results i wanted to
take a look at something i just talked
about maxine yeah my team's not happy
he's very angry at how badly he played
well in one tournament but i think in
the rapid events the rapid events he did
fine that's what i'm saying and
he did really badly in the sink field
right
he tanked completely in on the rapido in
the rapid and blitz that's right almost
winning it yeah i mean he
you know in terms of uh in terms of
winning in paris he managed to to claw
his way to the finish line and finally
win he was very disgusted but then also
in the st louis rapid and blitz
he just you know he needs to put it
together he and magnus played horribly
in that event
well
and we do have christian carilla from
bucharest
we haven't looked a lot at this game
between artemyev and koro
both of them being wild cards and
korobov once again is the top rated
player uh in this tournament in terms of
rapid rankings so in this position he
had a choice after bishop f1 he could
have just slowly played the position
with rook to d8 potentially bishop to f8
e6 and just slowly slowly build the
position instead he chose a very
strategically risky move and that is the
move b5 but this is backed up by a clear
plan the rook takes c8 rook takes a
knight to c5 and now immediately taking
advantage of the fact that knight is on
c5 and playing the move e5 white doesn't
have the option of taking on e5 and
messing up black structures so now he
played the move
queen to d2
b4 another question is
who has the better uh chances in terms
of ideas is black going to be able to
get his knight to c3 is black going to
close up the center with the move e4
gain space advantage and then
potentially launch an attack on the king
side is white going to be able to create
some weaknesses on the queen side these
questions are going to be answered but
to be honest i really like the way
corobo is playing this game
he is definitely up on time two minutes
and i think uh as we are getting closer
close closer and closer to the time
travel situation he will have the better
chances once the position
becomes uh unstable guys back to you
thank you christian certainly
an enterprising way of playing by coral
bluff and i like that he got this kind
of symmetrical position but never wanted
to go for a clear draw and he just kept
playing on and i think he has
very efficiently outplayed vladislav
artemy of something that's very
difficult to do especially from a
position that seemed kind of dry but
he's really turned it around and as
christian mentioned i really like the
way that he has made its own chances
from a position that was just pretty
dull and speaking of that i i do like
the way that some of the players are
putting pressure on uh today's games i
think anish gear is playing great with
the black pieces in this night or korvo
is playing great in this symmetrical
fiance groove field and
i also think that
despite the fact that maybe the engine
didn't like it i like how anand is
playing to me human this looks great
because i killed both of your bishops it
allows me to re-maneuver the pieces that
i have left i'm going to play strictly
on the dark squares that's where my
advantage lies so perhaps the computer
was happier with other things but i love
the way that he shut down the bishops to
me this is the sign of a great player
with the knights against the bishops is
being able to make them look bad it's
very difficult to make bishops look bad
they seem to just destroy positions open
diagonals but look at how the structure
has changed and how vishy has managed to
control not one but both bishops at the
same time both of them pretty much dead
and just slowly improves his position
methodically if you will i really like
the way that he's playing even if the
computers thought there was a better way
of doing things and by the way you just
played the move queen g5 eyeing that
pawn on c5
one day um taking all the pawns off but
that idea of h4h5 still very much alive
as well as knight f4 knight h5 popping
into the position a lot that black has
to worry about it's a little bit of a
stretch move because
though because we're getting five c5 is
not a threat it's not a threat at all
ever because rookie five will always uh
double attack the c5 and the g5 square
also also f6
yeah f6 will remove them you've got to
you've got to watch out actually
as you mentioned there is a move here
that he has to pay attention to that
could cause real trouble anand is kind
of letting the rope go a little bit
alejandro you know he
he gets this good position and the one
thing we noticed remember that game
against geary in the sing field cup i
mean he was just mauling
mauling geary and he just had to play
some knight to d4 and keep his attack
going instead he went off a little bit
and slowed the game down allowed gary to
get back in the game and he had he
counted five positions he should have
won he said if magnus was playing this
he wins five of these like no problem
instead
she managed to draw all five of them and
draw his way out of winning the siegful
cup he was no question the best player
in the event as far as the positions he
was getting from the opening and early
middle games so he has to be careful
that sometimes he's indecisive and
doesn't play the the killer hits your
move h4h5 for example the engine's love
like no question add the pressure go for
it instead he's kind of backed up a
little bit and there's a move here that
accentuates that the move rook to d3 d3
says
you definitely cannot take on c5 because
of f6 he's guarded the e3 square and
prevented you from touching the square
and the beauty of this move too is check
this out knight c1 chasing the rook
i'm not going anywhere i dare you to
take me why not night off but what's
wrong with knight f4 don't tell me you
can take on b3 because there's no way
that's happening
okay night knight f4 remember you're
still talking about an exchange is
rookie five uh-huh
what's your next move your queen has to
move
and then you'll take on b3 and the
promise i don't have queen f6 that's
kind of an important detail because i
have assuming bishop d.a that is winning
you are assuming correctly bishop to d8
and the queen is under attack so white
there there's a certain kind of
picturesque way of the way white is
playing white is playing these nice
pretty moves he's got the bishops buried
in the position
but concretely the dynamics start to
favor black as when position starts to
open up he could sacrifice exchanges
anna just did it himself sack in
exchange and the bishop start going hey
look at these nice open lines we found
in a position like the one we talked
about right here knight c1 rook to d4
you don't dare touch a piece like this
one and let this start to happen in the
game so he has he has to get over that
pretty move uh syndrome and start
playing the aggressive ones to knock the
guy out in the meantime
uh
shakur still has to find these
immediate rook takes d7 from vichy
keeping that edge on the clock
yeah it does feel i i still feel is
unpleasant for my mediocre guys i get
the rook d3 was a tactical detail but i
just don't think that
it really gets that much better for
black i do notice that rook d3 knight c1
root d4 solves so many problems but if
he didn't see it at that moment i feel
like there's still a lot of trouble for
a shock that's the danger he you know
when he plays aggressively chakra he can
make everybody scared but when he starts
playing positionally and slow different
kind of player it's not his strength and
there was something that i really didn't
understand you guys were mentioning in
the caruana game just to go back quickly
against wesley because we
i don't understand really this position
after
rookie one we left it off here and you
guys are saying black is fine and he's
solved his problems i just
i just feel like white is so much better
in this position i see the engine saying
that equality but
after queen d7 which i thought was the
best move queen c5 i just didn't see a
good way to untangle for the black
pieces you see this configuration with
the bishop on a7 and knight on b6 and
it's difficult to make a move because
knight c8 loses immediately soon bishop
takes ca tactics just work out for white
in this position so you have to go
something like queen c6 but then i get
my queen to e7 and then i get my knight
to h4
and maybe this is still holdable for
black but it starts to look really
awkward because you cannot really take
on e7 allow my rook there i don't still
have a good way to untangle my pieces
but white is kind of running knight f5
so perhaps i'm underestimating black's
chances but this feels like white is the
one playing with the initiative after
bishop f7 bishop b5 forced the trait of
uh
the queens and
maybe it's still equal i don't know guys
but i feel white's better i have a
knight on h5 i'm threading c7 i'm
throwing in g7
am i missing something clear
well we got the trusty silicon monsters
right always throwing ruining my party
some kind of ideas and bishop f7 was the
culprit as you mentioned this moment
right here it turns out that he could
have in fact traded here there also is a
bishop c6 move let the piece come in and
then play this move g6 and talk to your
knight now if rook takes c7 now this
bishop comes into the game as well and
the pressure from first of all this
bishop is a monster this bishop is a
monster he can always trade down this
pawn is going to be weak for a long time
and you have to find a move here you
can't really stay on the rank or on on
the uh on the seventh rank with any kind
of potency so black is going to prove
this position is dead your knight's
going nowhere if you have no attack this
d-pawn will be a sore spot for a while
and he's always threatening to take any
knight that shows back up on the square
and i think that's the main problem here
the way he played however allowed a
completely different direction
and g7 is dropped and that's a whole
different ball of wax knight c8 rook g7
bishop takes on d4 bishop to d3
threatening the pawn and bishop to g8
and this is not a construction that you
want to see if you are black pulling
everybody back and trying to guard the
position and now white has got to be
smelling blood somewhere what's the move
i don't know i don't see the killing
blow
maybe the silicon
finds it but
there are ways to improve the position
you could play knight f5 or something g6
and hope for pawn takes d6 well that
would be really
it is definitely knight f5 though
precedes a pace knight five bishop takes
what's going on with bishop f2 rook d3
nah but knight f6 and the knight of six
and you are going to be toast after
everything's over your bishop hanging on
g8 the game with levon by the way was a
draw so temporarily in the lead is the
lanaronian but
both ani shah and anand looking to
lead frogkin yeah he has played the move
knight f5 we just see that on the board
just a lot of pressure here for wesley
so it's not easy
for him to untangle the position it's
one of those situations in which his
position just never gets better he's
always going to be threatened with
checkmate he always has to keep the
bishop passive he has three weaknesses
to worry about c7 f6 and h7 and there is
nothing in his position that is going to
release the tension except for a trade
of rooks and that's very difficult to
achieve
it's not just flat out impossible i mean
i don't think that white's ever going to
give up that broke on g7
there's got to be a pawn ditch here
somewhere to relieve the pressure there
has to be there's no way you keep
everything no no you can't think about
keeping everything you have to lose a
pawn and ditch
and get this pressure off of you somehow
because otherwise you're going to get
squashed trying to keep the material so
what is it what is the sequence and he's
played
a very what is what's going on
knight d6 uh i take on d4 you just play
98 or some isu wow is that sound wait
does that actually work that what is
this knight takes
um
no it doesn't work he just dies
instantly that loses the game on the
spot for wesley so
you have rookie seven
you have you have knight takes d4
yes and rookie seven at the end hitting
the hitting the knight yeah because that
goes back and now you have it you're
getting killed you take you take and you
guys take and you take
this is hanging and yes they can't
defend it that's the problem that's the
end that's just that's just the end
wesley just blundered under the pressure
that was not the move to play knight d6
and he's now losing the game that's just
the three piece yeah if king g7 at the
end of that line you just take with the
uh the knight right and then this
position yeah just at the very end just
to go a little bit further so 90 yeah
yeah just to exemplify if you're king g7
you take with the knight to be fair i
think rook takes g8 is a winning end
game but why bother and i take jade is
just a free piece and then just king f7
rook moves and both pieces are defended
yeah there's no nothing here
uh
no that just looks like the end no it is
he blundered horribly
that's it and now he's looking at the
board never good when a per when you
suck a piece
of peace and now you have to resign and
you realize he just donated a piece to
fobby fab fabi surging back after a loss
wesley so crashing and burning and the
player again we will say who's smiling
a little bit inside is one maxim bashir
lagrave as wesley was one of the
contenders the worst wesley does in this
event the
less his chances of qualifying at all
because he has to play in india as we
said with the gang of four waiting for
him in that event he's going to be hard
to get points and if he doesn't get them
here he's going to be extremely
difficult as magnus dinglerand hikaru
nakamura and ian nepnacci
uh nepali these players
they're they're beasts at this time
control and it's going to be hard just
getting fourth or fifth which he's going
to need if he doesn't do anything here
he's going to need even second or first
well maxine won't be smiling for very
long if bobby keeps winning because that
will be another potential
um grabber of his spot well he has to
win first though he has to get first
clear first
he definitely does want wesley and anand
to lose but giri um let's take a look
and update us on his game against
carjacking just
look at the beauty of his pieces
compared to the ones from white
especially this king on h2 permanently
weak
and he has
yeah there's like no time for sergey
either this is ugly this is serious to
start playing blitz
yeah let's let's cancel the rest of the
rabbit no no i mean what i mean is you
know i've got 25 minutes on my clock but
i'm going to play blitz yeah i'm just
going to be like instant chess because
when he starts thinking it's when bad
things start to happen uh he's just been
it's incredible how much poorer he plays
at rap rapid than he does in blitz yeah
he does make it happen so jess queen
takes c4 maintaining the the fork uh the
rook on e2 is simply hanging he'll
regain the rook whenever he wants the
problem is that everything else about
white's position is terrible the pawns
are going to get picked off one by one i
think you're going to start with
the one on a2
i think he has taken
you know he's actually played king g7
trying to check my disappointment
because well why not i mean he's
bringing his rook in the king as i
mentioned was a permanent weakness
so sergey has to try to survive with
seconds on the clock
rookie probably doesn't survive
he's taking on a2 which is a little bit
of a weird move i thought he could just
checkmate him but he's just looking to
play rook takes c2 he's also going to
play rook takes c2 and possibly i mean
he can win whatever he wants he can win
the king said he can win on the queen
side it's crushing it's just it's
absolutely crucial c4 i can't just take
on c4 thank you for the pawn thank you
for the two pawns you gave me the rope
look at that now i'm still attacking
your king i'm up material rookie chad's
a thread b3 is a threat
oh my god okay this one is blood in the
water with only six seconds and he's
playing the move king to g1 the other
game by the way in time pressure is
chakra momojirov with 21 seconds only
left and on on also four minutes and 33
seconds we can take a look at that right
here we see the big lead but it's an end
game the queens have come off the board
and you can see that
anan doesn't have that same kind of
juice we thought he would have but will
chakra be able to keep on playing great
chess and by the way the c pawn is a
problem it's not as easy to just solve
it like blink and suddenly your c pawn
is
is uh demanded and gary did win he very
quickly the next move proved that he was
crushing geary playing amazing chess
he's in first place right now
yes and i believe that anthon karbov
will also win his game as vladislav
artemyev only has seconds left
but corabot should be able to convert
this opposite color bishop and he's just
queening upon
as you can see on your screen there is a
pawn all the way down on a2 for the
black side and he's going to force
another one on the king side with a move
g4 you just can't hold on to your
position at that point you can see that
g4 is coming into this position
not enough resources for
the wide side the spawn on b3 doesn't
really matter at all because the bishop
on b5 controls it perfectly this looks
completely dead to me
just a matter of technique here for
anton corbin off to win the game well
the game with anand then becomes the
most important one because he could tie
for first and what did he play
he
he played he have one
he's gonna lose on time oh
we had one second left on the clock
shaking he's got 11 it is torture time
and now he's backed him up and he's just
quickly traded has anand and he doesn't
have this move
i thought he's going to play rook d6 in
that moment 36 king f7 maybe didn't
improve his position that much but
he's kind of banking on this end game
being lost after rook two and getting
down in one second
boy it's panic mode now
uh no need to rush as far as i'm
concerned if i'm unknown just bring the
king to g5 and then figure it out
and now the knight is backed up and he's
just feeling like his knight is better
than that horrible looking bishop the
bishop has to leap to c2 to have any
kind of efficacy
one second what is up with this guy
you know what they say if you do it too
many times yeah eventually you're going
to drop what's the knight doing on e2
though is that f4
yeah and now you've got to defend that
well but this is yours
it's got to be a killer move
i'm actually not sure what it threatens
it doesn't matter
just put it there no i agree it's the
best kind of move the guy doesn't know
what it threatens whoa
that happened he had to do that
doesn't lose but he had to play it now
you got to suffer the rook's not going
to shift
there goes one little button on a5 you
can't defend it b6 will just allow the
move rook to b8 so there goes one and
now the rook is trapped what is fishing
doing because rook g8 is a bit of an
issue a little bit a little bit of a
trap well b4 can always be played but he
doesn't want to give the possibility he
really really doesn't want to play b4
but but hold on b4 does pick off the
pawn on f5 well
there's a big question what is black's
next move if you play b6 or k7 if you
play king c7 i'll run through c5 true so
you're not going to trap my rook if i
can bring my knight to attack c5 i just
win that is true there's going to be
some work to get it there because i
don't see where your square is that
you're going to attack the c5 pawn but i
think vish is also feeling the
nervousness from his opponent a little
bit he just has to breathe in and calm
down just a little bit because his
position is so dominant but where is he
the knight just returned the knight just
returned he's not clear on what he needs
to do
right at this moment to win the game
that's not so easy to figure out either
it's not maybe it's going to put the
knight to h
wow well repeating is not what he wants
well rick i'm surprised why not rook d8
now just what what
okay
hilarious actually what wait a minute
that's a three-fold repetition this
place is no
what is vishy gonna do there's no way
he's taking a draw
no way what
is it
what what is happening
oh and there it is
what
wait wait what yeah
are we no just the draw just the draw
no
i mean he must play the end game
wow and b4 is never a good idea he can't
figure out how to win the position
it's true actually i i wasn't looking at
the engine the engine is saying that
this position is now equal wow well the
problem was taking that pawn on a5 just
completely shut the rook off
the game yeah he had to play something
that threatened black's position the
part on a5 is really irrelevant if you
can't get the rogue back into the game
in fact yes giving it as a complete
blunder rook tate's a5 was a huge
mistake on his part
there's no obvious plan to make progress
as you shut your rook out of the game
stunning stunning development anan is
going to kick himself
this is the kind of thing he worries
about he gets this great winning
position against shakriar even down to
the end game even now to the guy having
one second on his clock and he still
doesn't win the game yeah this one hurts
and kurabob has also won his game um
also in addition to the other two
players in this round anish giri and
fabiano carowana so korrabof is plus one
plus one a great showing i mean he is
the highest rated rapid player
apparently in the tournament after
wesley saw lost his first game but
before that we have christian carrillo
with anish geary our leader
you're with the co-leader of the event
anish giri of course a joint leader with
vishwanathan
anish you're playing scintillating
attacking trust and it seems like
there's been a switch recently you
played in the european team championship
you're playing very aggressive and now
of course you're opening up with the
neither what happened people are
starting comparing you to tal and so on
what happened they're just trolling me i
think i don't think so no i've been
always playing different kind of chairs
i've had
many attacking games before but
especially in the modern times the
people they like to categor put you know
give out all sorts of cliches categorize
people you know and uh
you it's either um you know either you
are the biggest
uh yeah i can't find the word which is
not a swearing word so
i don't know biggest cat out there
or you're michael todd there's nothing
in between for people did you feel the
pressure from uh the media and social no
no i never i never
do because
i realize it's pressure is always there
and it's not always just sometimes
well it does sort of hurt me when i
myself think that i play uh poor chess
and that's somebody else says that as
well it's extra painful but when i think
it's okay then i don't mind but yeah i
mean i okay i play sometimes
interesting games always when uh now it
happened that they just come some in a
row and okay that's nice which one do
you feel was uh the move that kind of
sealed the deal no actually i was uh
just when i'm about to quit the night
off they always pull me back in with
games like that i mean
i i think the turning point was um
here
so he wants to bring the knight to e3
with gt393 which is a thematic idea but
here it's four it falls uh
it falls into should be a bishop a5
which is also a thematic idea and it
just doesn't work and unfortunately rook
is also a new one
so suppose he had the queen on d3
instead uh maybe g3 castle knight g2
bishop d8 knight e3 and then he's in
time he's maybe in time to go 95 i don't
think he's by the way by any means
winning or anything but at least he he
gets the horse to d5 and of course
against that i would have played
differently but here aj just falls into
bishop a5 and here he cannot even yeah
it's extremely bad version he cannot
even um pin somehow from and he's just
lost i think and maybe try to avoid this
pin somehow
i was hoping that he would i mean after
g3 castle if he would have still if he
would have seen that he would have
avoided it with queen d3 that's why
already
already here i was thinking to go bishop
d8
and i was not sure uh if i do it
immediately but i had a feeling he
doesn't see it otherwise he wouldn't
have played g3 so i thought okay i'll
castle and get it in a better version
um but yeah so here it is already too
late i mean i don't know yeah i would
have still tried to remove the knight
somehow i don't know maybe even to be
one or something i don't know maybe it
would be one and then at least you don't
get i don't know i did it but it's so
ugly i mean knight on your two knight
two only makes sense once it goes to d5
it feels like you go d5 yeah it's not
there it's not there for fun i mean it's
just it's serving a purpose of going to
e3 to d5 and once that fails once the
rook is only three the knight on g2 is
just totally out of place so basically
it was just about him blundering this
idea bishop d8 and then fortunately i
managed to convert
awesome game uh first of all
congratulations you're one of the
leaders going into the second day uh
what are your feelings about uh your
first time here at romania yeah i'm very
happy with today i
um
you know i'm always hoping to play well
but i didn't really
expect to win two games okay um
i think though there are so many games
to go and also the blitz and already
sergey bullied me he told me it's okay
i'll beat you in blitz so you know it's
it's not easy for me everybody everybody
bullies me so i'll try to continue the
good play and see what happens a lot of
personal grudges it seems but always i
mean people are holding grudge against
me always for no reason
okay good luck uh games guys back to you
and here it is the current standings on
each gary at the top of the table two
wins one drop no losses a big five point
so start out the super bad and then
right behind we have vision on and levon
aronian who both won their first round
games and drew their second two
um
their second and third rounds that is um
and they're joined by a wild card as
christian pointed out the top rated
rapid player in the world of the players
here sorry he's actually number six in
the world
um korevov well he's five now he passed
uh wesley i'm actually i think he was
well he was six and now he should be
should be fine yeah he passed wesley and
well well there's some games going on
maybe the hamburger is awesome i don't
know what's going on but grishok is
actually now number five so uh yep they
leapfrogging
no there should be some games left
because car above just one are going to
start timing all right right okay yeah
yeah
but point is goruba starting with two
blocks out of three scoring a victory
against artemyev i think that's a great
result for him definitely making his
mark in the tournament and
i'm a little bit surprised because i
thought artemia would have a better day
but he really got cleanly outplayed in
the first round by vichy and now by
korrabov both of them with the white
pieces but very sad day for wesley so
who certainly came into this tournament
in such a buoyant mood having won
against magnus carlson with a
devastating score
this is a real surprise i think honestly
if we had started this tournament with
predictions and they were blind
predictions meaning that we couldn't
hear what everybody else was saying a
lot of us might have picked wesley i
think some people would some people
would argue that it's been too much
chats for all the people that i play the
grand chess tour there's a couple that i
think this is just way too much in their
schedule i don't know how they do it
specifically mahmoud yarov and wesley uh
mamadiarov has played tournament after
tournament
after tournament i don't remember him
having a break grand prix world cup i
mean he had a break for the super swiss
but he's played so much and the same
with wesley he's played grand prix grand
chess tour world cup
he is playing pretty much everything
levon as well i just don't know how they
keep up their physical fortitude and
wesley having just played in norway just
adds another layer of tournament yes he
did amazing he crushed it he's world
champion
but what is your physical state after so
many times also that's a problem as well
sometimes you're full yeah you're like i
beat mac i crush magnus where else can i
go do i really care about the next
tournament you're full well one player
who is not so full because it's his
first chance to be on the tour is one
anton karbov and he's with christian
right now
of course maurice thank you very much
i'm here with anton korobov one of the
wild cards who is making quite an
impression in this event anton first of
all congratulations on the victory take
us through the critical moments of this
game
so here we have this position here
it's very difficult to get to grips
you're playing white or black that is
nearly the same here sometimes black is
white and white is black
so
the main danger for black here is to be
out maneuvered somehow yeah the lack of
coordination of pieces
so we played white logic called knight
on c5 this position knight d6
rook d1
or probably that is the first error step
on their own on the on their own road
here that is a kind of a prophylaxis
rook divan here protecting somehow after
e5 e5 fe5 and d5 is hanging somehow yeah
but i think this knight on c5 is not so
good here white cannot
make an active
activity with the heavy pieces i want to
ask you about this moment in particular
after bishop to f1 here you kind of had
the choice of maybe playing it slow uh
but of course he's trying to go queen to
a6 and but he chose the move b5 which
kind of okay gives him the score c5 but
it kind of completely uh makes the game
much different here but the problem is
that as a previous uh
uh play was a kind of brainstorming for
me
i did my best in order to organize the
e7 e5 and here why to play slowly here
it's time to sharpen up the scenes
so i think the f5 is quite an idea so i
was leaning on time here as well rook c8
knight c5 e5
uh so
in my opinion black is better here so my
plan may be to play before when he went
wrong
or the knight on c5 here that is the
wrong position too active to act
together and everything is kangen so my
plan is to play queen e7 somehow maybe
e5 just to start the attack in the
center yeah but after queen d2 before
ruxin bishop h6 yeah
i like this move here i'm trying to pee
in all his pieces but what is my threat
actually here so
i managed to persuade myself that my
threat is to take 1d4 and then to return
to g7 what we saw in the game take take
and i miss knight e6 and after this move
here
white is solving all his problems so
um
it seems like white is maybe even
slightly better but why slightly i think
i blundered greatly for example here
after exchange of all pieces rook s8
knight siege take on d4 knight e7 bishop
b5 we're very strange b3 f3 can i move
here yes f3 i was afraid of this now
the plan is very simple to play bishop
g3 bishop c7 take on a5 then take one
before and then to air to convert two
pounds
for example if i play the same like in
the game f5 bishop g3
take on d4 take on d4 knight goes to c6
and bishop goes to c7
and this sharp play can take on d4 he
can take on a5 but white is better and
you no longer close the bishop yeah on
this side with f4 here like he did in
the game and after here let's compare
this position here comparison according
to mark
here let's compare this position for
example after g5 there the bishop is
trapped the only idea is to play a tree
for example but after this
this pawn is very very dangerous
white needs a lot of moves by the king
to eat it and these spawns are also
vulnerable so i think here i'm solid and
here here my opponent decided here after
bishop eight bishop v6 okay
he wants to lose to lose the game
so why not and after you can just have
anything
can you press it yes yes of course
black is maybe is already winning here i
play knight of six and then uh
is different called bishop engine so i
think
the rules of the roof of two weaknesses
here one on five and second is here and
uh right
my white might be lost in my opinion and
the problem is if it goes a3 then you
create another password
will be enough to convert well this is
the first time uh playing in the
branches tour how do you feel after uh
day one quite a solid plus one also
you're the highest rated the rapid
player in this event
no second second no no wesley dropped a
lot of rating points so now oh yeah
you're number one
[Laughter]
how do you feel i feel like now i feel
additional additional responsibility yes
yeah
what do you do to prepare for these
games um every single day i think the
opening preparation is not so important
or for rapid chance you should mentally
be mentally ready here mental stress
with mental stress commit commitment and
physical power
well you've made quite an impression
congratulations against anton and we'll
see you tomorrow actually guys back to
you
thank you christian thanks great
interview there korov definitely very
candid with this expressions during the
game and i think that happens a lot to
us while we're playing we think we have
a good grasp of the position then
suddenly something goes wrong and we
have to readjust ourselves and that
readjusting can be very very difficult
and i think he had the clarity of mind
to see it several times during the game
where his opponent blunder it's okay
let's take advantage of this earlier his
own mistake allowing this with 96 which
actually gave vladislav the better
position
yeah great great interview no doubt i i
love to hear from the wild cards as
people we don't usually hear from and he
certainly is colorful and blunt
and that's what we like and we've got
final thoughts from christian gorilla
over in romania
we have so many stories after day one of
course anish giri is in incredible shape
is making a push and he's getting very
very close to those qualifying spots of
course final caruana started a bit slow
but he picked up his game and most
importantly i think psychologically he's
getting in tune with what uh the demands
of this tournament are and of course you
have stories such as anton korobov who
is just doing amazing and he's coming up
and he's talking about stamina and you
know mental preparation and so on i
think we have a very very interesting
group of people here and i'm looking
forward to the next couple of days
let's go back to maurice
well well said christian and
i loved what he said in the interview of
course and kerbov he said mental stress
commitment and physical power it's all
about making your presence felt is
basically what he's saying you've got to
come and bring it and show these players
that you're not afraid and he doesn't
look afraid at all he's showing his
style his power his strength and playing
great chess the bottom line though is
about the numbers somebody's going to
qualify for london and they're players
who are desperately seeking some points
carjacking oof he got blasted in that
last game and you see geary he needs to
win this event and come into the top two
in india he can't control anything but
game at a time but he's doing so far a
great job so we'll see wesley so by the
way
i mean he might be playing his way out
of this event because of the
the greed from getting so much stuff or
this or maybe it's the satisfaction of
winning in oslo so we'll see whether or
not you can pick it up it's an exciting
day indeed this kind of event maybe most
people won't watch because it doesn't
have all the big-name stars but it's
turning out to be an incredible show
well i have been absolutely enthralled
today and if this is any indication of
what's to come we're going to be in for
one heck of a ride yeah it's been a
really fun day i think several games to
take note of i especially like the way
that vishy played throughout the day and
even though he wasn't able to convert
there i guess my major with this blunder
rook takes a five i thought that his
games were so instructive all three of
them just the way that he played
powerfully i'm glad that i picked him as
my choice
not just because of the score that he
has plus one is pretty decent but the
way that he is playing in this game and
when vici is on fire that is always such
a pleasure to watch and i think there's
been a wonderful tournament so far a
great start off uh gcc to romania and
let's see how it continues join us
tomorrow same time same place
grandchester.org
and we're going to be starting at 2 50
in romania that is 6 50 a.m here in st
louis
can't wait
[Music]
you